are you out of your mind here's the
debate
you're upset
surprise if i ask you like if you put
vanilla ice at the top man that's gonna
be very weird if you do that anyways
folks
podcast says 156 150 what number are we
on tyler 156 and it's a special one we
have to thank somebody for today's
podcast i don't think with this
individual this would have never
happened i think spike you know this
individual very closely
uh on behalf of uh the entire pbd
podcast and the crew here today we'd
like to thank george jorgensen for
creating this uh
uh a unification of everybody coming
together she had some nice things to say
about you
and uh we talked a lot about
libertarians we talked foreign affairs
china border taxes yes we had a lot to
talk about that they would join i said
listen i put a question on the uh
twitter hey i'd like to bring a panel of
people
everybody was saying you gotta have dave
smith on you know and i brought it up to
rogan rogan's like this guy's an
absolute stud you've been on rogan
before you've been on rogan before
and spike you were the vp uh for the
libertarian uh yeah presidential uh of
2020 right
yeah larry you're running for governor
right now in new york hold on did joe
rogan not say good things about me joe
uh you know i didn't ask him about you
okay okay
actually you're gonna be talking
your stuff was like three or four years
ago right yeah but but we were having
dinner and the this the interview with
joe jorgensen came up because he voted
for joe and that's kind of how led to
you know all this other stuff and you
being a comedian rock star you explain
complex things in a very good way and
then we have also jessica vaughn here
with us we've been communicating bitcoin
community crypto community libertarian
community i said let's all come together
and see if we can do this podcast
appreciate you guys for coming out yeah
thank you of course so can i start off
with just a uh open uh question for all
of you guys and then you tell me where
we're going with this so here's uh where
i stand and why i'm more and more
curious with what's going on with the
libertarian argument so for me
i grew up in iran politically
you know mother side communist father
side you know
imperialism he believed in deshawn you
know what he was doing and my mother was
not she was more about the karl marx and
what a noble man and you know communists
manifest all this stuff so i grew up
thinking you know rich people are greedy
and poor people are lazy that's pretty
much where i was at right and i come to
the states and i really don't care much
about politics clinton was the first guy
i voted for i thought he was a pretty
good president and then i went back and
forth and then finally i've been
independent for the last 12 years but
i'm a big milton friedman guy so when
you look at milton explain you know the
concept of being a libertarian and he's
done a very good job we'll get into that
as well here in a minute i looked at the
data and i saw the kind of votes
libertarians were getting because we
need a third party raspberry was the
last guy that was able to create some
momentum to get a third party in 1972
year after libertarian party got started
you guys got 3 674 votes john hospers
in 76 was mcbride got 172 000 and 80 was
ed clark at 9 21 that's a big jump from
172 to 921 then it dropped to 228 84
david bergland then it went to 431 ron
paul then it went to 290 andrey monroe
then he went to a 485 in 96 with harry
brown then 384 harry brown again in 2000
dropped a little bit then 397 then bob
barr 2008 with wayne allyn route 523
then the big jump to 1.275 million gary
johnson then the big jump to 4.5 million
yep and then in 2020 which was like the
perfect year to take this to 10 million
with all the [ __ ] that was going on with
all the government regulating
controlling our lives making decisions
for us is drops this thing drops to
1.865
million that's nearly 3x down like 60
down 70 down dave i'm just gonna start
with you here how do we create that
momentum and then drop off in 2020 well
let me just say as somebody who's both a
big supporter of karl marx and the shaw
i think that we have to combine good
looking
combine their views and then project
that onto the world yeah well i mean
look i think you have to look at why
there was this big increase in the
libertarian vote uh in 2012 and then in
2016 and the truth is that i think a big
part of this was what was going on in
the republican uh presidential uh
primaries in 2008 and 2012. ron paul
kind of popularized and mainstreamed
libertarian ideas and this led to a lot
more people being open to vote for
libertarian candidates and in 2016 you
had uh the
by polling data the two most unpopular
candidates in the history since they had
been keeping this data in hillary
clinton and donald trump and so there
was this third option there and so that
drew a lot of people in in 2020 i think
that and you know spike can speak to
this better he was more involved in that
campaign um
i think that we did have a huge
opportunity this is part of the reason
why i joined the libertarian party i was
just a libertarian like a ron paul
supporter
um i think there's a huge opportunity
there to kind of spread these ideas and
get a lot of people interested i think
we dropped the ball in a lot of ways and
the lockdowns and stuff like that made
it harder for doing traditional
campaigning but
i don't think we need to do traditional
campaigning in the same way that we used
to i mean we have big platforms like
this and rogan and all these other
things uh so that's what i that's what
my focus is on is trying to kind of
spread these ideas to people because i
think this country is on a suicide
mission and the reason for that is that
we've abandoned the principles of free
markets of limited government of you
know libertarianism spike we were uh uh
he kind of pretty much said it's better
i ask you this question since you were
going through in 2020 yeah but
off camera we were actually giving
praise not you to aoc for aoc going out
there knocking doors because larry
knocked on your door so that to me shows
hustle when you look at lyndon johnson
back in the days when he ran for
congress the guy was known as a bmf who
was willing to come and sit down and
tell you i want your vote and that takes
a lot of work to do right shaking hands
doing all that stuff you know you were
in it you guys ran together you know
yourself and you i saw the bus i saw the
stuff that was going on what did you see
what do you think was the missed
opportunity and what was it like when
you were talking to people to convert
because the whole game is about
converting it's not to talk to people
that agree yes my biggest concern with
joe was when i spoke to her is how come
you haven't had many debates she
couldn't think about a debate so who's
pushing back who's challenging are there
people being converted i thought milton
did that but what did you feel was the
climate in 2020 i'm glad you brought up
that debate during the the joe interview
because and i do i think there was also
a big part of there was a lack of
messaging discipline when it came to and
this was something that i tried to do as
much as i could but i'm the vp candidate
you know it's not a 50 50 uh running
mate situation it's more like 95 five um
so i did everything i could to talk
about lockdowns and the mandates and
everything else um
that wasn't the main focus of the
campaign unfortunately and by the time
the shift happened in in uh summer where
there was more focus on that it was too
late at that point and at that point a
lot of the lockdowns were waning too so
it was no longer the big thing everyone
was talking about um but i'm glad you
brought up the debates because
the reason we didn't participate in any
debates during the 2020 race was because
the campaign decided not to um obviously
we couldn't participate in the
republican and democrat the the
commission on presidential debates
debate because that was that's a cartel
and they keep everyone else out but
there were opportunities to participate
in debates with other third-party
candidates and the campaign decided not
to
now i don't know why that was they said
it was because well we don't want to be
seen as being at the kids table
one percent two percent three percent
half a percent we're at the kids table
and we need to
take our position that we're at now
stand on the kids table and try to use
it as leverage to get up higher that was
a sort of microcosm of many problems in
the campaign we ran a really good
campaign for someone a candidate who was
already comfortably ahead by a couple of
points and uh you know didn't want to
rock the boat too much but if you're
trying to be a disruptive candidate
who's presenting a stark contrast to the
other two parties that wasn't being done
so so when that is happening how much of
counsel is being you know are they
asking you are you guys sitting in a
group is it a conference call is it a
zoom are you guys talking to each other
saying hey spike what do you see
happening what do you see is the
opportunity where are we dropping the
ball is is that mastermind taking place
or no uh the exact opposite was
happening uh i spoke with joe four times
during the campaign and i was told that
my opinions were not welcome what
but but let me let me uh how does that
how does that okay so who is there is a
spokesperson for the libertarian party i
i don't know the guy's name i've seen
him uh his name's larry sharpe he's
right here yeah no no no no a guy a guy
until you endorse he's right here right
yes but but the question i'm trying to
ask is like who's who's leading that
conversation isn't somebody sitting down
with you guys as a strategist and saying
hey
what are we is you were you really the
strategist leading that campaign no you
want to claim oh i'm talking about that
one yeah i'm going to talk about that
one before i get to you who was the
strategy
as a person who's ran a business as a
person who's ran a business and for many
many years
as a
younger ceo entrepreneur i was afraid to
talk about the problems that we had sure
until i realized we can't do this [ __ ]
we got to talk about it let's get in
there and talk about it so unless if we
address that we can't get past it to get
to the next level so
who who was a i think behind closed
doors there's got to be some strategists
that are like you know to have some of
the who was that person for you guys
there was uh there were people called
strategists but it would there not so
much i actually had to build my own team
because there wasn't a lot of feedback
happening from the actual campaign
structure the jorgensen campaign and
what little feedback i was getting is we
don't really want you to do anything or
say anything and we're not literally in
2018 i ran the biggest independent
campaign of 2018. we raised half million
dollars which is a lot for third party
right my opponents raised 6 million and
12 million respectively so obviously i
was blown out of water i built the
largest team
literally built a a policy library which
is still at larrysharp.com had a team
that got me on rogue and that got me on
glenn back that got me on all the shows
right
didn't ask me a question yep
did you actually want my team larry
actually offered
my entire game didn't happen i said take
my i built my team out i'm ready to go
let's go do this didn't happen didn't
happen and i'm doing it again now which
is why you said who's the person doing
it you're looking at the guy you go to
larryshop.com that is a libertarian
policy library you see what i'm doing
and i'm i i am in the least free state
as ranked by capable cato multiple years
in a row my policies have to lean
towards a horribly unfree state so
whatever state you're in you can easily
modify my policies and find them in your
state if they can work in mine they can
work in yours we're the ones who get out
there and do things we're the ones who
are making things rock and roll so if
you're looking for the future it's here
i don't want to talk about the past
anymore well i by the way i don't know
i don't know the past no no i said it's
here oh okay the future i don't i don't
know how new york beat uh california i'm
sure those cato guys have an answer for
it yes
so okay so you said if you go to my
website here's what i stand for why
don't you tell the audience what the you
run for governor new york as a
libertarian what do you stand for let me
bring up an answer to what to what um
dave brought up the answer is popularity
that's the answer
the answer i wish it was more that oh
i'm the smartest the best looking guy
that'd be awesome because i am both but
that doesn't matter the point is i have
to be more popular is the issue why
can't we get in debates debates are not
about whether someone is right or wrong
debates are about ad revenue that's what
debates are actually about so how do i
know that in new york when i ran i was
in debates right i've been in debates
with actual congress people i've been in
debates i've gone back and forth but
there was a debate in new york state we
don't use a presidential commission we
actually use the league of women voters
and they had an actual official debate
and in that debate our governor said i'm
not showing up
why he was winning hands down cuomo was
the homosexual remember that was
homosexuals they all loved cuomo he was
going to win he's the best guy in the
world so he didn't bother showing up to
the debate so it wasn't televised
so i showed up republicans showed up two
other parties showed up and i wanted to
debate handily and no one saw it except
if he were there that was it because it
wasn't televised so what happened the tv
station said wait a minute there's a
bunch of money to be made so cbs said
we're going to do a special town hall
with just republican and democrat that
debate was televised
so if they think they can make ad
revenue they would do it remember in
2016 and 2017 cnn was doing a bunch of
individual town halls with individual
people that wasn't because they cared
they were simply testing to see how much
money they would get in ad revenue if
any of them were popular they would then
put them in the debate stage it was
about popularity it wasn't about whether
they care or not the goal of the media
is to be seen and nothing else if we
understand that it's true popularity
matters people say larry how come we
didn't get in the polls because you have
to buy the polls to get in the polls
it's not about it's about cash right so
if i want to be in a poll
it's not just because i'm the official
candidate i found this out the hard way
i have to buy the poll a poll costs
about forty thousand dollars if i'm
raising millions i'll buy some polls
every week i'll buy a poll every month
i'll buy a poll when i'm raising half a
million dollars over my entire campaign
am i gonna be able to take ten percent
of that and throw it at a poll and maybe
come in poorly
probably not it's not not a responsible
use of my campaign funds right so you
have to buy a poll well why aren't you
in the press why aren't you in the press
because you have to buy ads to be in the
press
if you buy ads they then cover you if
you don't buy ads they don't cover you
it's that simple it's all paid to play
people get mad at me while you're asking
for money because i have to buy ads so i
can be covered so i have to buy polls so
i can be in them otherwise you can't be
in the polls and that's why people don't
understand third party there are so many
things how much money did you say you
raised you raised half a million dollars
half a million dollars yes this is one
this is 2018 2018. okay so so
uh okay so i sit with private equity
guys and
uh entrepreneurs will say when i'm going
around and i'm asking for money and
people are just not they're not they're
not giving me the money man if they
would have given me money i'll be able
to build the next billion dollar
opportunity
well maybe the messaging
or the product needs adjustment yep and
maybe the fundraiser the person
raising the money isn't doing a good job
selling whatever
we need to get behind because i like to
take the uh what do you call it i like
to take the responsibility on myself 100
and say hey let's if we're not able to
sell this guy our our pitch is different
so what like i remember like 20 what was
it 2020 was it 20 yeah 2020 when the
election was going on do you remember
that one tweet by joe jorgensen uh tyler
i don't know if you have it or not
and all of a sudden we get this tweet
about uh what do you call it uh
uh racism and black lives matter and we
need to be
so if you can make that big it's not
enough to be passively not racist we
must be actively anti
uh racist black lives mate standing in a
solidarity with a morning black
community as we fight together to
unqualify immunity police brutality
sentencing disparities and the war on
drugs not support of any organization by
the by that name okay so to me i see
that and i uh i don't know how you guys
process it i'm going to speak for myself
you guys can't say pat you're full of
you know you have no clue what you're
talking about
i see that
and i see somebody caving in to pc
community and you know political
correctness just kind of like hey
beating you down you better agree with
us okay let's throw this out there so
maybe we can get some independent voters
who are agreeing with black lives matter
okay let's throw so i can get some of
the democratic voters who come yeah so
that that argument then then all of a
sudden the people that are true
libertarians are like wait a minute
that's not what i believe in i'm out
well i mean look i was very vocal and
very critical about that tweet as well
as a bunch of other ones it was just
yeah it was just awful and completely
tone deaf i mean it's also like she said
it while the longest sustained riots in
modern american history were going on i
mean it's like
you know like people were terrified in
almost every major city across the
country businesses being destroyed and
then it's just like well it it's also
not libertarian at all the
libertarianism really has nothing to say
about how you feel
about other people if you are passively
not racist that's more than good enough
we don't require anyone to be actively
anti-racist whatever that means um the
truth is that look i was very critical
of george joe jorgensen during this
campaign i think that's why a lot of her
people around her don't like me very
much and why they gave her some bad
information that she came and shared
with you on the show um but i think that
it does
libertarians if we're gonna look like to
the fundraising issue before i think as
far as national candidates go the the
truth is that um ron paul at the time
broke fundraising records uh bernie
sanders then came in and smashed those
yeah and they didn't do it by going to
private equity guys
6 million on myspace and 24 hours that's
right that's right ron paul yes it was
and it broke records and he didn't even
set it up he literally just got into the
camera and said things that people
really appreciated and so what i think
is that the role for libertarians here
is that we're not going to out-compete
democrats and republicans in terms of
getting more money from private equity
or big banks or something like that
because we're not offering them what
democrats and republicans are the truth
is that if the libertarian agenda were
to ever be put in place big banks would
make way less money than they make right
now we're the party who wants to abolish
the federal reserve and make sure
there's never banker bailouts again and
that they don't have unlimited access to
easy money and that they can you know
like yeah i bet if i could borrow money
at zero percent interest rate and then
loan it out to the public uh for at four
percent i could do pretty good making
money too but we're trying to end that
scheme but what we can do is talk to the
american people who are being ripped off
by this whole system and get them
excited so that's so the problem with
joe jorgensen is that when you're so out
of touch with what's going on in the
culture right now and you just say
something like this that rightly by you
is perceived as caving in to a literal
mob um that doesn't get them riled up
in this time period while joe jorgensen
is tweeting that the american people
have the government has perpetrated one
of the greatest crimes against the
american people in modern american
history which were the lockdowns kicking
tens of millions of people out of work
with no legal justification just under
emergency powers govern governor decrees
we're many dictators now it's illegal
now for you to go to work and at the
same time they have raped the american
people just completely looted the
treasury and bailed out every giant
corporation in the country it was like
the most heinous crime committed against
the american people and in that moment
to stand up and say you know what the
problem is you average american you're
not anti-racist enough
that's the real issue that's what
libertarians have to say
didn't it
yeah i mean i lost all my income
immediately i mean i bled through my
savings in about four months i mean the
the um the closures the coveted closures
are definitely what red pilled me so
hard um i think uh joe's tweet is just
indicative of the old format
of libertarians trying to court both
sides
of it of the social of the um the
culture war but we're so deep into it
now that if you don't know that what
you're d if you don't define what the
dna of libertarianism libertarianism is
today like how how do we standardize any
type of messaging because that's very
contrary to the opinions of like people
on this panel that want to see
libertarians move more to the right on
these issues well and also i agree with
that and also just kind of knowing where
your best potential you know tar like i
want everyone to be a libertarian but i
could also recognize that there's
certain groups that are probably a
little bit more likely to respond to our
message and what you have going on if
you if you have your finger on the pulse
of the country is that you had um you
have a lot of people like on the
political right half of the country who
align with a lot of our views a lot of
people who really are fed up with like
the wars and the the deep state all the
three-letter agencies that that are fed
up with the lockdowns that are i mean
even after all the republican governors
by and large were awful on the lockdowns
we talk about like the two who were good
like desantis and and gnome the rest of
them all basically went along with the
program um and then you have a bunch of
people who historically have been more
left liberals who are completely turned
off by all this woke insanity and are
kind of leaving that so what you're
playing to with this message is the
people who what love the woke insanity
and our left liberals right this of all
the groups this is the least likely to
bear fruit for you so it's just even on
top of it being incorrect it's also just
strategically
stupid
where i wonder like
who are you processing issues with
before you put a message like this
because you're speaking
on behalf of 4.5 4.6 million people that
voted for this
concept this philosophy just four years
ago like who you strategizing with to
say let's go and do this that's what i
was asking about spike but jessica you
voted for obama 08 right you were you
were you were more on the liberal side
democratic side so what caused you to
say because everybody's selling their
philosophies what got you to the tipping
point to say you know what i kind of
like what these guys stand for
um
just on joe's tweet again do you think
that's indicative of the fact that she's
an educator and we know how woke the
how woke that went so big education i
would just like to weigh in joe has
didn't even know that was made it was
from a a speech that was written for her
at the convention and they clipped it
for the tweet so i i just want to make a
point that like she didn't do that i
don't know how joe jorgensen's never
been on her twitter but but i do want to
talk about this
by the way what you just said yeah what
you just said i hate to say this
eliminates her from ever running as the
face of the libertarian party what you
just said right there because if you
can't speak for yourself i'm sorry i
don't want i don't want you at the at
the white house and if you do outsource
that then it's your responsibility
i want to know what you're all about so
you were saying in the in the united
states in the wake of the killing of
george floyd and brianna taylor and the
protests and the riots that that sparked
there was an excellent opportunity for
libertarians to talk about the same
system that had uh unaccountable police
officers that were doing those things as
well as that same criminal justice
system that was letting people take over
entire communities and riot and pillage
and burn down buildings and homes it was
a great opportunity to do that
that's what should have been done that's
what i was trying to do in my little
corner is saying the same system that
this group's mad at is the same system
that this group is mad at and we should
be talking about that instead of playing
to the uh black lives matter versus all
lives matter culture war good cop bad
cop routine saying you're all being
scammed and lied to the way forward is
to fix these specific policies or end
these specific policies that led to what
we're experiencing right now and if we
do that then we can both reach people
across the board we can actually have a
moment of unification and we can wake up
some people that are looking at all of
this and saying i don't think anyone is
speaking to the actual solution to this
when you go once hard one side or the
other when you when you start uh
using too much of the the verbiage and
the and the the the tone and narrative
of one side or the other you're
signaling well i actually kind of
support this side well if you're trying
to get elected then you're basically
saying yeah i'm like this guy except i'm
less likely to win or i'm like this guy
except i'm less likely to win but if
instead you provide a stark contrast and
say no no here's why they're both wrong
i hated when i would get interviewed and
they'd say do you agree with trump on
this or do you agree with biden on this
and i'd say here's why they're both
wrong and here's what libertarians
believe and that was the problem with
that tweet and with a lot of other
things is that instead of trying to
provide a stark contrast between the
republicans and democrats and how they
both work together to fail us on this
instead it was well on this i agree with
this side more and on that i agree with
that side more well why are we relevant
then well no i want to touch if i can
right
i got the most votes in new york state
for the libertarian ever we had never
made been an official party in 50 years
how did i do that it wasn't by using any
of this rhetoric it was by creating
actual solutions that both sides could
accept right so one of the things i talk
about is the mta in new york city is a
disaster and my nose you see it's
horrible right so one of my answers was
why don't we lease out naming rights to
bridges there are a dozen bridges in new
york city right so why is the george
washington bridge or the verrazano
bridge why isn't the 3m bridge or the
kellogg's bridge or the pepsi bridge or
the google bridge they'll drop a hundred
million dollars on a valuetainment
bridge
we'll get you up on the center of the
valuetainment absolutely right i would
actually understand it 100 and bankers
did they actually came to me in my
business world i'm a business consultant
i deal with a lot of uh finance people
so they were like this is a good idea
larry so we front loaded 10-year 12-year
lease we front load the cash 100 million
dollars up per year that begins to pay
for the bridges that takes care of
maintenance no need for tolls who pays
tolls working poor middle-class paced
holes the wealthy nukes that are live in
new york city so what happens is all of
a sudden we get a solution and the
wealthy pay more which is what the left
wants but there's no extra taxes so it's
what the right wants the left and the
right are both satisfied i've got better
bridges more money coming into my city
and the working poor and the middle
class are taken care of that is what
made people go huh i didn't say i was
libertarian i didn't say i was democrat
i didn't say i was republican i said
here's an answer and people went oh
we're winning as libertarians if the
person in front of me assumes i'm them
and what year was that about 2018.
and you're chalking that up to you uh
speaking to the people about issues
correct i think you're wrong tell me
please i'll tell you why i think you
actually were successful
for the exact reason that george
jorgensen was not okay because you're a
charismatic leader it's freaking obvious
you got some
some bass in your voice like i like
listening to there we go if you would
pat if you still have the numbers for
what gary johnson did in ron paul and
joe jorgensen i'd like to just recap
that because it's so clear what was
wrong with joe jorgensen do you have
those numbers 4.489 joe jorgensen 1.865
and what was ron paul ron paul well that
was that was that was this is jim 431
but ron paul ran in 88 in the
libertarian party but he got we are now
living in a social media age adam i
would tell you i would i would tell you
that some would say that gary johnson is
also the cure for insomnia
and you know if you know what that means
you know yeah so it's not like exactly a
charismatic
nothing against them i would sit there
and i would watch and i'm like
like there was a moment one time with
gary in the 2016. aleppo
no no i'm just sitting there i'm like
give me
yes sell me something yeah and fire me
up like tell me what we're gonna be
doing that's exactly my point yeah you
guys do not have a messaging problem you
guys aren't gonna bicker over what your
policies are like she might be a policy
wonk you guys need eyeballs you said you
had a popularity problem the only way
like let's be real here if you guys are
trying to get from two percent to five
percent who gives a crap if you're
trying to get from five percent to 25
yep you need popularity you need
eyeballs you need a kanye
but brother i don't know if you have
that popularity you need a kanye you
need up next to this guy
right here awesome then if why don't we
do this that's what you guys why don't
we do this why don't we do this okay
for let let's assume
uh the average person
if you were to ask them what
libertarians are
uh based on the fantastic job that media
is done they're gonna say well listen
aren't they supposed to be like the
crazies aren't they like the
whole party by themselves okay so
i think you're you're the best guy to do
this if you don't like taking a moment
sell us
on the concept of being a libertarian
what is it to be a libertarian uh we're
the people who are right about
everything no um well listen the liberty
libertarians the five-second version
to me the libertarianism is i mean the
philosophy is the belief in
self-ownership the non-aggression
principle and private property rights
but we really are the believers in true
americanism the declaration of
independence and the bill of rights is a
great way to kind of sum up what
libertarians believe in and libertarians
are the people who have been warning
americans for decades that this country
is on a suicide mission because of our
military industrial complex bleeding our
treasury dry destroying our currency
locking up all of our people more than
any other country in the world the
national security apparatus the national
spying apparatus these are all of the
things that we've opposed for decades
and have largely been right about all of
it that's to me what libertarianism is
all about and we can speak really to the
issues that the the real crises that the
american people are facing to me that's
more or less what i you know in a very
quick version what i'd try to say we're
about let me give you can you can you do
me with everybody just turn off your
phone sometimes some phones verizon
especially will do that is it you're
going off no mine's off okay so if you
guys can turn off your phone for
whatever reason i caught that a little
bit right in the middle of my awesome
elevator
verizon so if i could be clear
libertarians say you can be as liberal
or as conservative as you want to be
just don't force your views on others
localism to where the government's job
is protecting the rights of the
individual from the local bully that's
the critical aspect how it should work
if you say to yourself i am super
liberal go great do you think it's the
government's job to enforce your world
to be more liberal if you go yes you're
a democrat if you go no it's my job
through my works through my through my
example through my community to make the
world more liberal you're libertarian if
you go i'm super conservative great is
it the government's job to make the rest
of the world more conservative yes
you're republican if you go no it's not
the government's job it's my job through
my works through my community through my
example to make the world more
conservative you're libertarian that's
the issue if you're saying i want to be
me
and you can be you you're a libertarian
that's it it doesn't matter what your
conservative liberal outlook is it
matters do you want to force someone
else to be like you
right in my state new york state we it's
a very diverse state in fact queens
county is the most diverse county in the
entire nation the most diverse entire
nation so i got people saying in
brooklyn who will tell me brooklyn is a
blood type they love brooklyn so much
who are very much anti-gun and i have
people in say allegheny wyoming county
who think if you want my gun yes
someone's gonna die so they have that
that difference and guess what they're
both right
they're both right if you don't want to
have a gun don't have a gun if you want
to have a gun have a gun if you want to
have strict control have to control if
you don't don't but stop forcing others
to be like you
it's okay so that's yours and then spike
what's yours how would you present the
libertarian party my five second version
is that libertarians believe people
people do best when they're most free
now
you talked about the uh the media
manipulation that libertarians are the
crazies libertarians want everything
that everyone else wants we want good
education we want good health care we
want a civil society we want people to
be safe we want people to live in a safe
society and so forth we've just
recognized that having government
control every single aspect of society
is a uniquely bad way of doing it and
that has been the problem government got
involved in health care they're ruining
health care they got involved in
education they're ruining education we
can go down the line with that we
recognize that the more local government
is the more accountable to the people
government is and the more allowing
people to make decisions voluntarily for
themselves and working together with
others the better off things are going
to be and to dave's point the warning
we've been making is that
it doesn't even matter if it's
republicans or democrats in charge when
it comes to things like the debt when it
comes to things like endless wars when
it comes to things like you know the
cost of everything spiraling out of
control it just keeps getting worse and
worse and worse and worse and it's not
because of uniquely bad politicians or
political parties it's because of a
system that was built to keep the people
that have power in power at everyone
else's expense we've also had some
pretty uniquely bad politicians yeah i
agree yeah i agree with that that's a
feature and not a bug
just got about yourself um i think that
it's the woke against everybody else and
there is a great pool of uh democrats
that we could could uh take
that um
just think all this all this is insane
and they're really harvestable people
especially uh bitcoiners that type of
thing they're all learning about
libertarianism because they they never
had an any kind of way to even know what
that really has meant
so so that that's a very good point
because to me
uh i don't know who we had on was it
michael i don't know who we had on it
was somebody that we had on we were
talking i said listen
my opinion is the crypto community is
becoming a political party and somebody
better win them early before somebody
else does i think that that party is for
you to take about 100 so i don't know if
you guys are going after that party and
this party's not going to get this small
it's going to get bigger and bigger and
they're right here in miami we already
have plans in new york state to allow
new york state to accept cryptocurrency
for all taxes fines and fees that's part
of my policy right that we can make
cryptocurrency the norm right so we
already can do that 100 so i i want it
i'm sorry go ahead and bitcoiners didn't
really care for eric adams because he
was like oh yes we're going to be very
pro bitcoin and then he you know did
things with
against other people's um uh rights like
making them do the um you know vaccine
mandates and all that stuff for masking
in schools like just
very contrary positions to being a pro
bitcoin person so we saw right through
that we even want nuclear power in new
york state so that we can actually
create a very easy blockchain mining
right we can make green blockchain
mining we can allow that we can support
that in new york city new york state is
the worst by the way for cryptocurrency
because we have a bit license
which was the absolute scam magnum
lawski decided he used to run our
financial um agency so then he created
this insane maze to get a bit license
then left and now he's a consultant so
you have to pay him hundreds of thousand
dollars to get the license that he
created
that by the way is legal it's just
unethical yeah totally legal yeah right
i would also say just to the idea of
cryptocurrency and specifically bitcoin
that libertarians have to recognize how
important this issue is because this to
me is like the most important thing um
in in the same sense that hundreds of
years ago you know the separation of
church and state was the most important
thing that really ended religious wars
you really don't have religious wars
anymore unless there's governments who
are you know in bed with religions who
are trying to impose themselves on other
governments and what we need today in
the united states of america more than
anything is the separation of money and
the state the separation of banking in
the state this is the cause of so many
of our problems right now is that the
currency is controlled by the government
this allows us to spend way beyond our
means to to pull things off that we
could never pull off if the government
wasn't just printing money out of thin
air the entire idea that we're going to
go around and you know occupy foreign
countries for 20 years in the middle
east with nothing to show for it try
doing that if you had to actually tax
the people the money try gaining popular
support for that if every month people
had to pay for the war in afghanistan
that thing would have been over by
christmas of 2001 yeah and so and so
many of these things and the same thing
with the lockdowns i mean try
maintaining the lockdowns if you
couldn't just print up trillions of
dollars in 2020. there's no way it could
have been done so this is really like
the federal reserve and the money
printing is the lifeblood of the
leviathan that's what we need to attack
and that's why bitcoin is such an
incredible you know like has so much
potential was that those people should
be libertarian wasn't the whole impetus
of creating bitcoin yeah two thousand i
believe i believe so when satoshi
nakamoto was like i don't like this uh
bailout drama that's going on in new
york city and wall street and occupy
wall street and that's how we started it
was essentially a cause and effect of
exactly what you're talking about dave
yeah bitcoin cryptocurrency blockchain
that's all libertarianism applied to a
problem that is a libertarian solution
to a statist problem so coming out of
the bailouts and tarp and too big to
fail and all of that the realization
that the the the central banking system
that we have is basically a game of
monopoly where all of you have to play
by the rules of monopoly but when it's
my turn i go over to the banker and say
give me a trillion monopoly notes and
stick them all with the debt for it what
would happen in that game is exactly how
our how everything is playing out right
now you have a small handful of people
who get richer and richer and richer
because they have the access to the the
funds the money that's being printed out
more than anyone else the cost of
everything's going through the roof
because they can spend want and lead
because it's not their money there's mal
investment that's leading to uh you know
these bubbles in the economy the the
real estate bubble the stock market
bubble uh the student debt bubble all of
that is because money's just being
thrown around when you get government
out of that when you have the market
deciding what money is then not only do
you not have the rampant inflation that
you have right now but you also don't
have the rampant government spending
that you have right now you don't have
the endless wars like like dave said you
don't have the the cronies like you know
like larry said that get to you know
build a system for them to become be a
millionaire for the rest of their life
all of that goes away because now
government has to do what literally
everyone else has to do prove that they
have value in exchange for the money
they get that's what you do with your
business that's what i did with my
businesses you have to prove that you
have value in exchange for money if you
and i could just walk around with a gun
legally and say hey give me all your
money yeah we'd be very wealthy we also
wouldn't provide much value
that's the problem we have and bitcoin
was a perfect example of instead of
trying to find a political solution to
it finding a market-based solution to a
problem that is still affecting and and
just on top i think sometimes people
have this like kind of attitude that
like okay you're talking about monetary
policy you're talking about economic
policy this is almost in this realm over
here of economics and then there's this
realm of like social issues but this is
this is like it's the most evil thing in
the world man i mean if you look at
think about i mean the way inflation is
just destroying people and who's it
destroyed it's not it's not destroyed
yeah and i think if you actually measure
the cpi the same way they measured it in
the 70s it's even higher than that at
this point the cpi is all kind of bs
anyway i mean it's like they don't
really account for housing and energy
increases and how you know if you're
talking about measuring how this really
impacts people and who does it impact
well not wall street speculators not
billionaires who own hard assets it's
impacting people on fixed incomes it's
impacting you know the retired and the
poor and the working class and this
government spending i mean you go look
at like um
uh i think it's i might have this double
check man i think 10 of the top of the
13 richest counties are all the suburbs
of washington dc yeah i mean these are
the people who are getting rich up it's
not like this is the bastion of
capitalism there aren't big factories in
washington dc producing everything
they're just the politically connected
they're people in bed with a weapons
company that funds a think tank that
comes up with a piece that we actually
need to go send a whole bunch of weapons
to ukraine
and this is like in the the real
application of all this is like that
families get broken up that men put
revolvers in their mouth and commit
suicide that kids are like like lives
are destroyed this is this can't be
removed from a social issue this is
actually and then you look around and
you're like why is the social fabric of
this country like falling apart why is
everyone turned on each other why do we
have such low like cultural standards
and all of this this is all related this
all like kind of came as a result of the
government destroying the economy well
financial sanctions too um are financial
controls on people um this censorship
wouldn't have even been anything anybody
could have thought about three years ago
but now i mean i don't know why
conservatives don't see that they can
just turn your bank account off i mean
look what happened in in canada with the
truckers or um even as something is as
uh big and broad as like with um the
russians and having the swift payment
denied to them you know why would we
give financial sanctions to citizens for
what the movements of their government
do yeah they always convince you it's
going after this bad guy so it's kind of
like hey we're seizing all these assets
of these russian oligarchs and you're
like well was anyone like convicted of
anything and a court of law is no but we
said russian oligarch so we're just
going to take all his stuff or the
truckers are like the bad people up
there these these working-class people
who are like and you're a putinis if you
think that's right and then all and then
you go like okay so they they uh invoked
these never before used emergency powers
act in canada and they're seizing
people's bank accounts
no due process no one ever proved that
they were at uh uh one of these protests
or donated to one of these protests and
even if they are i don't think they
should have their bank accounts seized
but yeah these type of powers are very
creepy and you know i think americans
are more and more waking up to the idea
of it's easy to be like yeah but the
government would never use them in that
way
but also yeah we never thought the
government was going to lock us in our
homes for months on end and you know
covet and these lockdowns have helped
your political party yeah have a bigger
voice it should help you well it's
helping me they've provided an
opportunity for should have we have to
actually take it and a bigger part of
that is yes we have to show that we have
the best ideas yes we have to show that
we actually have a solution to this
endless good cop bad cop routine between
republicans and democrats where we just
things just keep getting worse and worse
whether it's lockdown tarp the thing
that sparked bitcoin the outrage was an
800 what was a 798 billion dollar bail
that's pocket change to what they spend
now they routinely spend bills that
start with a t or end with a team you
know it's a it's a trillion dollar bill
it cares three billion two three
trillion billion yeah exactly 800
billion dollars is like a rounding error
now and and that's only in the span of
like less than 20 years it just keeps
getting worse and worse but the other
problem is that
libertarians
over 95 of voters either don't know who
libertarians are or they see us as even
if they agree with us even the majority
of libertarians self-identified
libertarians who do not vote libertarian
the reason they don't is because they
see us as a joke they see that we they
believe that we can't get elected and
they think well why would i bother doing
that i'm going to try to figure out
which side this time is marginally
better than that you say that stat one
more time 95 what well i mean look at
the numbers like the highest we've ever
gotten is uh what would three point
something percent with with gary and
bill and that was in a time with
uniquely uh with with terrible
candidates with uh trump and hillary
like unpopular candidates uh trump
didn't have the following he did in 2016
that he did in 2020 he's the most
popular libertarian out there
i'm pulling holding now in new york
state about six percent no but in the
country in the country the most popular
history
nationally yeah nationally who's the
most popular libertarian clint eastwood
is not vocal okay uh you got uh 185
years old vince vaughn is not vocal okay
you got rand paul that's very vocal but
you know again uh republican he didn't
run as a libertarian
yeah yeah you know you got ron paul who
is d.o.g the guy that knows how to sell
it better than anybody else that he's
but he's aging he's not you know so you
there's there's a few of them i mean joe
rogan could be
conce he voted for george organ he's
going to support the libertarian party
um but you know those are the names they
don't have like you need a face
please i'm the guy running let me tell
you this right now let me be very clear
we do have faces it's just hard we got
guys like shane hazel running for
governor in in georgia we got uh we we
got uh mark tibbetts running in texas
i've if i've never heard of the names
you're saying yeah then you don't have a
face we have ricky if i have to go
google ricky harrington yes because i've
never heard him by the way google ricky
harrington whoever do that bits is yes
you're missing the point here i'm not
i'm here trying to get this out you need
nobody like you need a tom hanks you
need a rock you need that okay but it's
so clear even though we have tom hanks
or a rock we still have to show people
how our ideas work that's not the debate
though but literally you guys know what
you're talking about please clearly
let me deal with this for one second i'm
telling you why they're not coming to us
because we don't have the infrastructure
to support them it isn't our ideas we
require infrastructure why would you run
libertarian when you'd have to fight to
get enough people on the ballot you'd
have to fight to get on the ballot
period you'd have to fight to get
signatures fight to come up with a bunch
of people who could support you fight to
find a funding base
you don't want libertarian because you
don't care libertarians you don't want
to return because you can get a you can
get it but i don't know i don't even
think you're if the rock ran as a
libertarian they'd have a hard time yes
let me be very clear i'm sure behind the
scenes you're right
but you would get so many eyeballs and
it does not matter
that's the difference
more votes yes would they win absolutely
not and another big part of that is but
that's the step by step it is step by
step but there's another step-by-step
process which is doing that the majority
yeah but i don't know if you're popular
enough i like you i think you're
charismatic the majority you're not the
rock brothers guys let me let me hear
what spike is saying hang on hang on
if you were correct yeah then michael
bloomberg would be our independent
president
he's not
be why the system is is set up to not
work i don't think i'm gonna save the
world but do i think i could be the guy
who sets it up for the world to be saved
yes i do because i am building out the
infrastructure as you said step by step
like we're not doing it i'm literally
here doing it it is being done so that
in 2024 in 2028 when kurt russell
decides to come aboard or drew carey
both libertarians one of those two guys
come aboard we have an infrastructure
set they're happy to do it or whomever
is the rock comes over we don't have
enough to give them now but we have to
build up and we are that takes local
people building up local groups local
infrastructure
donor bases our pr bases all those
things to make that happen
can i oh i'm sorry go ahead and
the vast majority of voters long before
they want to they trust the libertarian
to handle the wars or china or
immigration they want to see how they
handle their pothole in their in their
neighborhood like libertarians have won
hundreds of local races hundreds out of
literally tens of thousands we've won
zero statewide races we've done zero
federal races we've won
zero of them yes there's ballot access
problems and everything else but there's
an even bigger problem which is that
most voters even if they hear our ideas
they go yeah that sounds great in theory
but how's it going to work in practice
we need to focus local we need to build
an actual infrastructure for the party
to work our way up because if we get a
dwayne the rock johnson he might will he
get double digits as a libertarian yes
is he going to win it absolutely not
because people at the end of the day
they're going to go yeah dwayne dronson
great rock great but this party i know
nothing about them they've never won
before what would they actually do if
they did one uh you know i'm worried
about
the the kitchen table issues like health
care and education and housing and the
cost of living and everything else and
just the fact that a very popular guy is
running or or woman is running for
office is not going to be enough for
them to say okay i'm going to break free
from the system that's been running this
country for over a hundred years now we
have to build the infrastructure so i
think we need them and that will also
bring a big name why would the rock come
let me read a super chat here from
hector ross larry knows what he's
talking about howard stern openly
contemplated running libertarian as new
york governor but backed out for lack of
infrastructure at the time i have some
feedback there but i want to hear david
and i want to kind of give you what i'm
what i'm thinking go ahead okay so i i
tend to agree i think we're almost
talking about different things here i
mean look if somebody like the rock was
truly converted to libertarianism and
like i believe this now and i want to be
like the champion for it that would be
amazing i mean that would be incredible
what it could do for us and so i agree
with you on that but the thing is this
right you've basically had over the last
uh let's say
10 15 years right you've had
essentially third party candidates who
ran within the two major parties so ron
paul was a third-party candidate in
spirit he didn't believe what the what
the republican establishment did bernie
sanders was essentially a third-party
candidate and donald trump essentially
won as a third-party candidate however
the way the system is set up in order
for them to do that it's not to their
advantage to go to some third party to
their advantage to stay in one of the
major two parties what we're sitting
here saying is that the problem is that
that never actually works for what our
desired outcomes are which is really
rolling back the state now donald trump
i agree with spike kind of yeah if he
had run third party that would have made
it a lot harder for him to do what he
needs to do i'd love for that famous
person who can move
people by the tens of millions to come
over to libertarianism but in the
meantime what are we supposed to do what
are we supposed to do are we supposed to
accept that these two parties who have
in effect committed treason against the
american people and we know nothing's
going to be solved from within them that
what we're just supposed to fall in line
because this one is five percent better
than the other one like that's not good
enough for me i don't think anybody's
saying that well my point is that this
is the united states of america we
deserve something better than that and
so we're gonna keep fighting to try to
get this message out to as many people
as possible to hopefully put us in a
situation where we can get somebody like
that so or whatever's necessary to move
the needle look i agree with you if tom
hanks or the rock or some crazy famous
charismatic person wanted to take up the
mantle for this i'd be thrilled but
since we don't have that right now i the
best i can do is try to get on as many
huge platforms as i can speak to as many
people as i can build up our army you
know metaphorically speaking not a real
state army um and and try to you know
monogram these views yes and
non-aggression
yes exactly um well it sounds like you
guys need to be able to walk and chew
gum at the same time yeah because i
didn't know that about the libertarian
infrastructure like i'm learning that
we're all learning that but it sounds
like you guys need to build out the
infrastructure
but also get someone that gets eyeballs
because joe jorgensen's not the answer
we all know that let me let me give you
let me give you a little
census but that's who your candidate was
by the way did you guys all vote for joe
of course i did yes i voted for joe 100
they did not you did you vote at all or
no no i abstained did you vote you voted
i did joe oh no i voted for trump okay
got it okay thank you for telling us no
i voted for jojo i'm happy about it so
so let me let me say let me let me say
this here so
um i'm processing everything you're
saying and we've talked about that
before and i'm processing what you guys
are saying
uh here's what i would compare
uh libertarian to if it was a religion
don't get upset here i'm just telling
you if you were a religion it's my
religion i would say you're like
scientology okay
and they have famous people they do i
was about to go there i was about money
i was about to go there i was about to
go there to say scientology for the
longest time has been trying to sell and
if you go to scientology in 2002 i was a
guy on the streets going every church
i'm debating everybody i'm trying what
is this all about and i'm an atheist at
the time and i would go to scientology i
would say so so tell me who is god who
do you think god is
no no i'm asking you who is god who do
you think god is
i said no
i'm asking you you're a religion you
have a 501c3 under that tax code you're
structured as a religion you got that
tax code back in the days you had great
lawyers who is god
who's got to you
i i went everywhere asking people who is
god they couldn't tell me who god was
right that's what okay so whoever you
want god to be that's the argument
whoever you want god to be is your god
okay how about this who do you want it
to be whoever you want it to be so the
philosophy
is very much about whatever you want to
do is you're whatever you want to do
whatever you want to do right okay
you know
that attracted some people on whoever
you want to be on ron hubbard wrote all
these books dianetics has started with
that and all this other stuff and next
thing you know
adam that kind of counter
contradicts the argument of having a big
name because they've had all the big
names over the years i mean you can't
get bigger names than these guys got
right you're saying scientology but they
haven't gotten bigger their membership's
going down it's not it's not at the peak
it used to be now maybe it's because of
miscavige maybe it's because of whatever
i'm not going to talk on that all i'm
saying is that part now let me go to the
other side
um
there are roughly 200
libertarian politicians out there almost
every one of them is local okay
you have a justin homage who ran as a
republican switched to a libertarian
michigan i want to say yeah and then
he's like i'm done right then you have
jeff hewitt who is the highest ranked
libertarian i don't think it's riverside
county in california he has a job there
and then you got a couple other guys
that are doing what they're doing that
are highly ranked right okay so to me
i think uh what you're doing is great
you got to go out and promote your
message and do what you're doing but i
think you guys got to get more grass
root on the bottom
to get more people selling locally yeah
that's right and yeah it's to sell
people locally and then go to the top
now what would help on your end because
yesterday i'm like i'm sitting i'm like
listen i have a painting in my in my uh
club room in my house and a painting has
milton friedman there i'm a milton
friedman guy and milton friedman what
made him unique remember that michael
moore debate with milton friedman i
don't know if you've ever seen it or not
michael moore 17 years old you ever seen
this was that really michael moore yeah
i've seen people say it was young
michael moore but then i saw other
people be like that wasn't mike no but
the people that's that's michael moore
who was debating the whole pinto
something else right so he but he was
all about debate right okay which is
essentially a little bit of the what's
going on right now there's a little bit
of pushback so let me see how this guy
sold it so the founder of libertarian
is this guy named nolan right david
nolan he starts in 1971 right of the
party colorado springs so why did he
start this what's his motive okay so it
was inspired by the austrian school of
economics not uh ludwig von mises it was
more maury uh rothbard and that time
when the party got started it was
because of four reasons one was nixon
okay what he was doing his
administration they were not ford is the
vietnam war why do we have to do this
whole conscription i think it's like
when people are just getting drafted
without a choice and then it was a start
of fiat gold standard that was the time
where he kind of switched listen guys we
got to do something about this so he
created us nolan chart and started going
around to everybody and talking about
hey left hey right you may not be what
you think you are you may be this and oh
[ __ ] this kind of makes sense the world
smallest political quiz by the way you
can get that quiz on the advocates.org
if you want to go to that quiz and it's
easy small yeah simple place the
advocates.org the world's smallest
political quiz so there is an interview
milton friedman does i think everybody
has to watch i've one of them is filled
down here if you haven't watched a 45
minute one part one i believe you got to
watch him when he's talking about a
nader i think he's someone nader but
there's another one that i watched that
he is being asked about the libertarian
party so what's the libertarian party
and he says look there's two ways of
libertarian party i've debated yarum
burke before i was a host of one of the
iron events that took place a few years
ago in newport beach one he says is the
iron rand one which is like nothing like
everything you leave everything around
and then there is the
version that he is more for which is hey
you know there's a little bit of a you
know consequentialist libertarianism he
explains then the guy starts asking
questions saying which one of these
federal government agencies do we need
to abolish which one of them to keep out
of the 14 that he's asking the question
department of agriculture agriculture
abolish department of education abolish
department of commerce abolish
department of defense keep it department
of energy abolish half put the rest
under defense okay department of health
and human services it's interesting what
he said he says well
yeah we kind of can but we need it
because of contagion and pandemic and
things like that the prominent housing
and development abolish he said this one
hurt america the most by the way housing
and urban you know housing and
development department of interior first
you have to sell the land that the
government owns why does the government
owned on this land he says should
government have any land except for the
buildings that the government works out
of everything else give it to the people
you shouldn't own all this land
department of justice keep it the
problem of labor abolish department of
transportation abolish department of
state keep it department of treasury
keep it to collect taxes was the main
thing that he talked about department of
veteran affairs abolished
this is not fda cia cdc nih fbi nhs deaf
the atf which atf makes no sense alcohol
tobacco firearm what the hell we talk
about atf today and we got all these
people working for them yeah
so so so what so that's how he sold it
then he said the government's role
is a few things preserve the peace and
defended the country okay which is
defense
provide a mechanism whereby individuals
can adjudicate their disputes justice
department right protect individuals
from being
coerced by others individuals you know
police and leave that at the state and
local level so
that's how milton sold it which part of
what milton said do you guys disagree
with today because this was nearly 40
years ago
well all of that would be a pretty good
start
um so i think like i am more of a roth
bardian than uh than uh friedmanite um
i'm more i'm a libertarian because i
believe in natural rights and i believe
that government destroys people's lives
and i find that morally egregious um but
i do think that this kind of
consequentialist argument is important
also that things would work a lot better
uh if we left you know like voluntary
human action dictate them and markets
and rather than you know top down
authoritarian states um i think that
all of
there's so much of the federal
government that needs to be abolished
that getting into like whether or not
he's completely right about keeping the
justice department
i probably disagree i think that could
be handled by the states better
if in terms of keeping the defense
department i mean there should be a
drastic rollback of the
military-industrial complex the defense
department does not specialize in
defending this country they specialize
in starting aggressive wars for very
specific corporate interests at this
point there's not been a real defensive
need for the defense department since
certainly not in my lifetime um but you
really believe that
uh that what military he's 100 percent
correct what military action has in my
lifetime has there been one war that was
a justified defense of war well let me
let me ask you questions well okay 911
certainly was a result of a lot of
military intervention preceding 911 i
mean the the people who attacked us on 9
11 were people who we were sponsoring uh
teaching them how to lure the soviets
into afghanistan and bleed an empire dry
uh we then you know radicalized them
against us and certainly i don't think
that's the angle i'm going through 911
is a byproduct of jimmy carter's bad
policies back in 1979 with the human
rights movement that he had he asked to
shaw to release 3 000
prisoners that he had in the 3000
prisoners that were released ended up
turning into isis and all that other
stuff so that that well hold on but
there's there's a lot of there's a lot
in between there so but also jimmy
carter in the last year as uh zabignu
brzezinski brags in his memoir that they
they were working to lure the soviet
union into afghanistan to give them
their own vietnam and then in the reagan
years we armed and trained the what was
the mujahideen in afghanistan which was
osama bin laden and the same group of
guys who turned into into al qaeda we
then under uh uh barack obama sided with
al qaeda and isis in libya and syria and
in yemen gave them a whole bunch more
weapons and and stuff like that so
there's been i mean yes 911 was awful we
should have in response to that killed
and captured the the people who were
responsible for that but that has
nothing to do with that has nothing to
do with uh regime change war against the
taliban yes we could have cleaned that
up by christmas of 2000 but you're
saying we don't need a department of
defense not what he said okay you're
saying no we don't need 730 000
employees of department of defense yes
we don't need the trillion dollar a year
empire which we maintain what about the
hundreds of bases all around the world
800 to be able china's got one base
close every single one of them and bring
every single troop home we're not
supposed to be an empire we're supposed
to be a republic and we have no need for
our country for our defense it does
nothing to help the american people this
we every one of these troops should come
home protect our country protect our
borders that should be the role if there
is one of the federal government so so
for example
so this is this is where i want to kind
of get into some of the issues
so if war is taking place in other
places and the country is getting
stronger by strong arm and other people
and picking up countries left and right
we should stay out of it
yes
if it doesn't threaten our country then
yeah but let's just say russia well
let's just stay out of it russia picks
up ukraine guys don't do anything china
picks up hong kong guys just don't do
anything you know chance like listen
we're big enough screw it australia
seems weak why don't we put a 10-year
plan to go take over australia guys just
don't do anything
does that also mean as other
uh power empires keep getting stronger
and stronger and stronger we just sit on
the sidelines and do nothing
once they get to canada i'd start
getting the best way to deal with the
china threat is to look at why china is
a threat china at one point was a
country that was starving to death by
the tens of millions we have to look at
why that actually happened why they've
gone from that to being arguably the
second large second or possibly most
powerful country on earth and it's
because of the fact that cronies in the
u.s and other western countries realized
that the best way they could protect
their market share of their various
industries that they were in was to
create such a high regulatory and tax
burden in the u.s and in north america
and in other western countries that they
would basically shut out all the rest of
their competition create such a high
barrier to entry that more disruptive
smaller competitors could not compete
they did that knowing that eventually
they would they would poison the water
so much domestically that even they
couldn't produce here but they were fine
with that because they were already
working to develop a good cozy
relationships with dictatorial regimes
overseas like china and then use the us
military to protect their goods and
services that they're making over there
all the way back here to sell back to
the american people that is the problem
the root problem of china is that the
the us and the west the regulatory and
tax structure in this country i mean you
run businesses i ran businesses it's so
high that there are people that are
moving all their jobs over there if we
made it more fertile ground for people
to do business here people are going to
want to do business here instead of a
country that's telling their company you
can't even criticize us or we won't let
you work here we won't let you operate
here i i think that's right and i i also
think that um look that we have to be
somewhat realistic i think that the the
america the hubris of the uh american
national federal government and its
spokespeople is so out of control that
people have this like empire mentality
so the question becomes can we let china
take taiwan should we let them do that
you know now i don't want the chinese
communist party to rule taiwan i would
rather taiwan be more free than less
free i want everyone to be free the
truth is that we cannot stop them from
doing that and the idea that we somehow
it would you want to go to an h-bomb war
and destroy half of the world and then
they still take taiwan after that we we
do not have an option to have a direct
military confrontation with russia or
china humanity cannot survive that in
the broader picture if you're talking
about countries dominating other
countries i don't think there's too many
examples where a poorer country goes and
takes over a richer country that doesn't
tend to happen it's a richer more
powerful country that takes over a poor
country okay the best defensive against
that is happening us and our allies be
as rich
the answer to that is free market
capitalism that's how you produce wealth
so you want to keep your economy as free
market as possible so that you are as
wealthy as possible and therefore not
vulnerable to being taken over i got a
follow-up for you but you want to say
something by the way i said i said hong
kong earlier is taiwan correction
thank you for doing that go ahead what
you talk about they have abolishing and
policing
that also i don't talk about that's
milton friedman talked about you were
bringing that up yes the problem you
have with that is when you say those
words the average american gets really
afraid because what the government is
always said here is a monopoly
so there are many communities now and
the lockdowns told us this they have
lost the institutional knowledge to
support themselves because they've been
supported by government for so long they
literally cannot support themselves so
if you just knock down that government
monopoly they will have nothing and they
are afraid of that also for many of
these communities they're in a bad spot
they are kept down by government and
employed by government so now when you
take government away they are no longer
kept down but they're also no longer
employed so we can't just we can but we
shouldn't just abolish government what
we should do is support the community in
supporting itself right there are
policies you can do to begin that one of
the policies i had is if you are a new
york state resident and you're going to
you know pay your taxes at the end of
the year you can take up to 250 of that
you would spend send to the state and
instead send to any nonprofit and if
it's a local non-profit supporting
localism it's 500 bucks you might go 500
bucks how much is that what if it's a
thousand thousand people doing it 10 000
people doing it you can begin to support
nonprofits locally community
not government-sponsored nonprofits
government-sponsored nonprofits are
simply government agencies that are not
unionized but actual local communities
that will assist and get the communities
up and running people do need help i
just believe in my heart and that
everyone here does communities and
families are going to be better at
supporting people than some government
agency if we support that first then
government will either go away or
somehow get better if we can get better
but it'll just begin to go away because
community will support community and
that's the piece we have to begin to
support communities first so okay can
capitalism stand on its own without uh
law and order
oh no well i mean you need laws in the
world
but i mean look what you need but just
to be more specifically uh to be more
specific what when we're talking about
law and order let's be clear about what
we're talking about what you need is the
protection of people and property yeah
like that's very specifically what you
need that people and their property need
to be protected against aggressors now
whoever you think should do that that
service certainly has to be done the
problem that we have today under state
policing is that at for
they're always either doing more than
that or less than that right so you
always you have things where you have uh
uh gun control and the war on drugs and
these kind of militarization of the
police and tens of thousands of swat
raids a year where it to the point where
like you know my uh my my friend uh tim
poole who you know on the tim cass show
he's been swatted like multiple times
because it's that easy to just swat
someone yeah you can literally just call
them and go oh here there's they're
holding people or they're killing people
here and they go and it's by the fourth
time it's happened the the the police
department isn't going yeah we probably
don't believe you because you've already
done this three times
so
we have this one thing where we're
they're going well beyond protecting
people and property and they become an
authoritarian force and then we have
other examples in a lot of these blue
cities right now where they're doing
less than that not protecting property
not protecting you know not you can
shoplift up to a thousand dollars in san
francisco or whatever exact the rule is
and that leads to chaos so what you want
to find is you want to get as close as
possible to the perfect equilibrium of
protecting people and property no more
and no less so i i personally i think
private security it does a better job of
that than state police do so i'd want to
see that expanded as much so so that's
the issue right why do we have things
like why is possession
of a drug a crime
right that's the type of thing we're
talking about why is some activity that
doesn't hurt anybody why is that a crime
are these a victimless crimes is selling
get a crime why would it be a crime
selling cocaine a crime it is a crime it
should not be
it is a crime it shouldn't be correct
because it's my choice whether i want to
buy it or not i can go to the fda yeah
and i can get a drug that will get me
hooked on opioids should anything be
illegal to sell
when i asked joe this question should
anything be illegal to sell yes there
are issues that you don't want to sell
certain things to certain ages of course
you can have age restrictions on things
to sell 100 should i be able to sell the
super emp's should i be able to sell
nuclear to help you have nuclear power
should i if you got the money you got
all the billions that maybe i want to
sell it to you as an individual well
should i be able to sell that if there's
someone who can afford to buy a nuclear
power there's a lot of guys today that
can yes if they can buy nuclear power
plant and they want a nuclear power
plant they're going to get a nuclear
power plant if they actually want it
they're going to go get it it doesn't
matter and no one has so this is a
question that libertarians get asked a
lot because we're we're against the war
on drugs and the war on guns and so
people will go to the extreme and say
well what about nukes it's important to
note that no person outside of a state
or government has nukes right now not
because they can't get them but because
who else but a government would want to
have nukes in fact the entire nuclear
energy system we have right now which
was originally built more towards the
production of nuclear weapons than
actual nuclear energy which is why it's
not as efficient as things like thorium
plants and things like that is because
it was government leading the way on it
saying well no our top priority is
having nuclear bombs before they
realized that it would destroy the
planet and that they couldn't use them
as freely as they were using them like
in hiroshima nagasaki that was going to
be a new arsenal that they would use all
the time but the point of that is absent
the need by a central authority by a
centrally planned authority to rule over
others there's not really a good reason
to have a nuke it's not something you're
able to be able to use uh
good reason you have a lot of things
though there's i'm just asking like
hold on the only question i'm asking
nowhere near i'm asking a question wait
a minute but no one knows i'm asking a
question because i'm asking the question
to challenge the philosophy if there's a
limit to the philosophy i'm not asking
it because tomorrow i want to buy a
nuclear weapon so let me let me go to a
different area let me touch this piece
this is common well then we'll we'll all
die we'll all explode the world will end
let's start having those conversations
let's start having conversations on what
type of machine gun we can have or
whatever let's have that conversation
not whether i can defend myself in my
home we are so far from what you're
talking about it's it's on the planet i
don't know this i don't think we're far
from what i'm talking about i actually
don't think we're far from what i'm
talking about we're living in a time
right now that
uh we're two to four years we're gonna
have multiple trillionaires people gonna
have money to be able to become more
powerful than many many many many
governments and countries around the
world but let me go to the other
question that's my biggest concern larry
and i really want you guys to tackle
this okay
so 800 military bases we lead in the
world okay
we can probably go away with 90 of them
some say we can go away with 100 of them
china's got one it's in djibouti
specifically because of oil and the
whole
you know where they're targeting to
control their oil where they're getting
it from fine let's set that aside but
i'm going to go back to what i asked him
and i actually i'm curious to know what
you say to this
say a
country
keeps becoming a bigger superpower
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
and bigger
should we do anything about it or should
we just leave it alone say guys don't
worry about it we're in america what do
you mean we're protected what do you
mean specifically do something about it
like what are you what would you be
proposing to do about it say a little
guy calls and says hey man dave i need
your help bro they're about to take my
ass out well if should you say dude it's
not my business but i'm handling my own
business well here i i look at it like
this right so i personally i would never
advocate for a war that i wasn't willing
to fight and die in myself and so in the
same sense of like if i you know if you
were saying there's um
there's uh children you know in your
neighborhood somewhere who are at risk
would i risk my children in order to go
help them
the answer is almost certainly no and
that's just i don't mean to be cold
about it it doesn't mean that i don't
have any sympathy for those kids but my
first priority in life is protecting my
children and i kind of look at that
extended out now we the bottom line is
we are not supposed to be an empire
we're supposed to be a republic if
another country does want to become an
empire which i also think the truth is
that we are by far still the richest
country in the world and we can't afford
the empire that we're maintaining we're
30 trillion dollars in debt trying to
maintain this empire i don't think
there's any other country who could
really maintain it for long that doesn't
mean they can't squash some of their
smaller neighbors along the way
um i think that it would be reasonable
to do everything in our power to try to
negotiate a
peaceful solution to a problem so in
with russian ukraine right now forget
all the meddling that the united states
of america has done to help create this
mess i would i would not have a problem
with a massive diplom
diplomacy effort right now to say hey we
need to reach a deal to have a ceasefire
here vladimir putin's going to get a
little bit of what he wants he's not
going to get everything he wants let's
try to end the war let's try to end the
bloodshed should we it go to war
to defend one of these other countries i
think if you want to strap on a helmet
and a pair of boots and grab a gun and
go over there and help them more power
to you brother i wouldn't stop you from
doing it again should we force the
american taxpayer to pay for this
especially when our own country is
falling apart absolutely not so in other
words what you're saying is let me
restate this one more time
if china
keeps picking up pieces
on the puzzle
small little countries
and they're bullying them and russia is
doing that as long as we're sitting here
and it's not affecting us at all we
should just leave them alone we
shouldn't do anything to those guys
again i don't know if i'd say we
shouldn't do anything i mean like i
think you can condemn people you can try
to predict them
they don't care about condemning that
doesn't bother you no i'm not saying or
putin i'm not saying that that's going
to stop but you just use the words
literally do anything if you're talking
about should we go to war with
nuclear-armed countries for other
countries no i don't agree okay so let's
say let's say let's say let's say guys
this has been going on for a long time
let's say
they go and all of a sudden out of the
200 countries that we have okay whatever
numbers 195 to 205. it changes let's say
it's 200. at the 200 countries that we
have
all of a sudden we're down to 180.
160 140 120 100
60 50. right you're okay if there's only
20 countries in the world and one of
them becomes a superpower because they
can
i'm certainly not okay with it
let me just say i'm certainly not okay
with it but in the same time i almost
feel like this mentality it's like
you're in a marriage and your marriage
is falling apart and you're sitting here
worrying about the marriage down the
block and going like oh i think their
marriage is really on the right i'm
saying well i'm saying our country is
falling apart and it's because we've
tried to be the empire of the world let
me give you an actual all of this i'm
the policy guy let me give you i'm not
i'm not the theory guy right this theory
guys i'm gonna give you actual policy in
two things how do you destroy the
military complex and bring the empire
back and then how do you handle that
what you just said let me first test the
military industrial complex the military
complex while we have the empire is
because of money that's only reason why
we have a bunch of contractors who
literally make trillions of dollars on
these things what we must do is we have
to immediately end all hot wars all of
them end bring those troops back to
bases that we currently have and or to
the states
allow their normal contracts to end you
do not discharge them immediately i know
some of the people said that's a
terrible idea you can't discharge the
millions of troops in america with no
jobs and break all their contracts you
don't do that you mean don't allow
re-enlistments so you allow their
contracts to end and they know in
advance because people plan their
families around this hey you're not
going to re-enlist plan your life around
this two years you're going to be out or
whatever or limit reenlistments this
brings our military service down that's
number one number two all the countries
that we're now deciding that we're not
going to trade with open up trade with
all of them north korea cuba iran all of
the open up trade completely and give
preferred treatment which makes some
libertarians unhappy but i still say it
with the military complex to not give
them weapons but to give them trucks and
computers and whatever the military
industrial complex doesn't want to kill
people it just doesn't care it wants to
sell stuff and make money so give them
the opportunity to sell stuff and make
money not killing people they will begin
to transfer do that while you do that
you slowly begin to look at every single
agreement we have these bases some are
sofa agreements some are alliance
agreements and you look at all of the
deals all of them have some out contract
where there's time or things happen and
you let every one of those out you get
out of every single one of those bases
as the agreements go you don't want to
break your contracts but all the
contracts have ways of getting us out
within 10 years
you will have almost every base removed
with the exception of those that are
required to protect trade routes
i think we should retain bases with our
naval forces that protect trade routes
besides that bring all the troops home
let them go away now how do i stop when
someone's grabbing all these countries
no one's grabbing those countries that
scenario you made up is a total fantasy
country
to be naive to say that
you have to be naive to say that no you
have to be naive to say that larry
russia can't take ukraine how naive of a
statement is that what do you mean there
were more countries what europe would
have happened
so you're telling me there is no
countries that want to take over others
i didn't say that you said 200 to 50 no
way i said it like okay so let me let me
never gonna happen do you want a life
insurance policy i do why do you own it
because i'm gonna die one day okay so do
you own it because you're gonna die
tomorrow maybe one day i'm gonna die but
you're gonna even die tomorrow maybe
you're gonna die the next day maybe
today maybe today but do you know
do you know
no i don't okay do you have a nuptial
agreement do i have no i do do you have
estate planning do you have a landing
trust do you have a will do you have it
okay
so for me
the only thing and by the way the
military-industrial complex nobody
disagrees with that yep nobody on the
left or the right or the middle disagree
and those who do they're involved
correct nobody disagrees with that part
let's set that part aside
all i'm saying is the argument to think
that all these other guys are gonna sit
there and say okay for example how come
uh russia didn't uh invade ukraine under
trump
how come uh that's how i'm gonna be
clear
i am saying that because that to me is i
have to have a life insurance policy
against that happening and if i don't
have an insurance policy against that
somebody will take advantage of it it's
called nuclear weapons well we don't we
have to we have an insurance company so
so that's a nuclear weapon that is
defense of course so you need a major
defense so the enemy knows to not screw
with your country
but there is a big but that we're going
with here and i want to get spike's uh
feedback on this this is the one part
okay that we haven't yet you still
haven't addressed okay
if
a smaller guy
smaller country is being bullied by a
bigger one a putin or regime yep or you
know anyone these guys
and they're going and imposing
themselves on them yep should we sit on
the sidelines and not do anything about
it
i i need to answer exactly so the united
states military industrial and i know
you're saying that no one agrees with
that but that's what we have so when
you're saying do something that's the
thing we have you know they literally
say fight with the army you have the
army we have spent 20 years and tens of
billions of dollars to replace the
taliban which they helped to create with
a better armed taliban that now has the
support of the majority of afghanistan
people so that's the problem they spent
they spent over a trillion dollars not
tens of billions of dollars well just on
the military we left 83 billion dollars
of equipment for those guys 83 billion
that's a lot of equipment yeah that's
when you're saying do something that's
the system we have what's much better is
to look at why china and these other
countries are potential threats to begin
with quick quick poll here anyone raise
your hands who think that state
communism is a great way to run a
country and that it will become a
powerful empire as a result of communism
exactly no one thinks that the reason
it's set up that way is because the
other powerful economies are
intentionally choking themselves off so
that a small handful of cronies in those
countries can have a controlled market
where they are the ones that control the
market by having control of the the
labor and the production which is
controlled in china and china's
benefiting from that you just had the
g20 countries every year the g8 or g7
now because they kicked russia out but
then all the major economies get
together and they talk about things like
minimum global minimum taxes and they
talk about things like climate change uh
controls and they talk about all these
different regulations of taxes and they
all congratulate each other on it and
china is completely left out of it and
they sit there and go that looks great
we're going to continue to have the most
competitive economy because these
countries are intentionally choking
themselves off and they're not doing it
because they're stupid they're doing it
because the cronies that put those
politicians in place in all of those
countries are benefiting from that
they benefit they make the billions they
deal with not having to have nearly as
many competitors and china's just
sitting there and reaping the whirlwind
from it if we get rid of that if we do
deregulation here you're going to see
masses of jobs come back or honestly a
lot of them will just wither on the vine
there and be replaced with much better
businesses and more disruptive
industries here
as a result of that and so now china
will have to sit there and say okay do
we want to be a communist regime that is
now falling apart because the us isn't
uh choking itself off economically or do
we have to create an actual free market
or do we need to have a freer market so
that we can actually feed our people
they're not even going to be thinking
about empire they're going to be
thinking about how they don't go back to
starving to death by the tens of
millions yeah i would i would recommend
this is first off i would recommend
people read david stockman you know who
david stockman is he was reagan's budget
uh director he's a brilliant i haven't
read the book but i don't know well he
wrote a couple great books the great
deformation was incredible i recommend
people read that but i'm talking more
about his articles that he's been
writing about china and he's completely
convinced that china is in a huge bubble
that this is not that they're going to
have a huge crash coming up now i'm not
i don't know shannon's been saying that
for 30 years yeah well okay maybe
they're wrong i'm just saying that is
another possibility here too i mean they
really have like if you think what our
fed is doing is crazy i mean they're
really like a ghost economy in a sense
that being said though i don't think
i i don't think it's it's like
impractical that bigger countries are
going to squash little countries and of
course i think this has been happening
for all of human history this happens
all around the globe and i think there
are a lot of people who you know get
innocent people who get crushed in that
process i think that the difference
between your hypothetical and his spike
is talking about like what we really are
living in is that so i guess
theoretically if you made america the
kind of benevolent good guys who some
big country was trying to impose their
will on some small country shouldn't we
be the good guys in this fight kind of
like disinterested and come in and say
hey no big guy you don't get to impose
your will on this small guy perhaps in
theory in reality we are the big guy who
imposes our will on the small guy the
greatest purveyor of violence in the
world is the united states of america's
federal government over the last 25
years in the 21st century there is no
question you look at the hundreds of
thousands if you add up the war in iraq
in libya in syria in yemen in somalia
what we've done we're in the millions of
innocent people who have been killed as
a result of our wars perhaps we are not
in the position to claim that we are the
guy who stands up for the little guy
being bullied by the big guy no that's
not why we're on the side of ukraine
that's not why we're on the side of hong
kong that has nothing to do with any of
it this is strategic interest from very
interested people who are blood-soaked
monsters who don't have anything to say
about the hundreds of thousands of
people being slaughtered in yemen right
now as babies starve to death in yemen
that war in yemen could be ended with a
phone call from the president of the
united states telling saudi arabia we
will not tolerate this war of genocide
going on and they don't pick up the
phone call the phone to make that call
because they're benefiting from that
partnership with saudi arabia this is
not okay so humanitarian impulses do not
drive u.s policies we will not tolerate
unpack the meaning of we will not
tolerate what do you mean we will not
tolerate if you were look saudi arabia
and the united states of america have
been in a partnership since the 70s and
they're both and saudi arabia is they
need that partnership with the united
states of america the obama
literally said and you can google this
and check it out to placate the saudis
he helped them launch the war in yemen
we were refueling their fighter jets for
the first seven years of this war a war
of genocide where people are dying by
the hundreds of thousands when this is
all said and done i bet you it's over a
million people who die in the war in
yemen once they get the real numbers
including the like cholera outbreaks and
all of that stuff this is the poorest
country in the middle east yemen before
the war the poorest country there poorer
than the poorest people we've ever met
in our lives people who live in the
united states of america they continued
it all the way through the trump uh
administration biden promised he was
going to end it they've been escalating
it what is that
my point is that they could if the
united states of america put serious
pressure on the saudis said listen no
more weapons no more deals unless you
find an end to this war there's no
question that they could end this thing
they could have ended it by just never
starting it under barack obama they
could have ended it by donald trump
coming in there and just not but donald
trump was like oh we're selling a bunch
of weapons to the saudis this is great
business so he kept it going but i'm
just saying if we really want to be
humanitarians and we really want to stop
a bigger country from bullying a smaller
country well you've got a bigger country
in saudi arabia committing genocide
against a smaller country in yemen where
we have tremendous influence over them
it'd be much easier to stop that than to
stop russia or china let's start small
go do it one time and then maybe i'll
believe that the u.s federal government
is in the business of uh protecting the
small from the big i'll i'll give you an
answer you ask what that means as i said
you retain protection of trade routes
so people stop doing things you don't
like don't protect don't protect their
trade routes
it's again non-compliance can still make
it happen not trading can be something
you can do if we are as dave says the
most powerful if we just said open trade
for everybody i just said open trade for
north korea iran for everybody who's
north korea invading
who what big what little guy are they
invading nobody but if you're worried
about a big guy invading someone if
that's your concern there are other
things we can do besides we think south
koreans go to sleep good at night
hundred percent no it's not literally
not there but not you think they're not
worried about the guy but they're
they're worried about nukes i mean
they're not worried they're not worried
about north korea not dating south korea
they're worried about them launching a
new guy that's a part of it
no i think that's a fear yes you have a
nuclear arms badminton so but the fear
is not north north korea is too pleasant
but go there go there and say north
korea nuke south korea what should we do
wow i don't you you just go to places
like that why in the world with north
korea guys
they're korean i'm a as a as a person
who was just thinking from the
we have a guy right now that the
conversation i had yesterday two days
ago we have peter pryor dr peter prior i
don't know if you know who he is
he is the leading expert for weapons of
mass destruction and nuclear weapons and
super emps and you know experts are
saying if they drop a super emp 70 of
america is going to die within 30 days
sure this is a reality and so there's a
lot of [ __ ] going on today so for me to
sit there and say guys don't worry about
it it's going to be chill nothing's
going to work but that's not the same i
don't know where you're going i just ask
you a simple question you're telling me
i'm not a question it's like what if a
nuclear what if it
this is not everything though well this
is i'm from iran buddy i'm this is not
coming from a guy that's an old this is
like we're living in atlanta in america
where there's no horse here there's
somebody nukaron half a million people
die between them and iraq yes by the way
yes
by the way because the united states was
funding and supporting
both sides we were given the most in
that war if if north korea today okay so
let me let me go back to what you said
you said something here so well if we
take this route and you know here's
what's going to be happening and you
know they're going to see us as the good
guy saying hey guys don't do this etc
etc okay
if if your last name is trump
when you go to school but you're not
donald trump but your last name is trump
if you go somewhere you're going to
school or you're doing business you
introduce yourself as
hi i'm barron trump are you going to be
judged yeah yeah okay
if your last name is kennedy and say hi
i'm robert kennedy jr are you gonna be
judged sure of course i am your last
name is clinton i'm chelsea clinton how
are you do you immediately go to uh oh
i'm dealing with a trump a kennedy or a
clinton yes okay
if you are representing a country whose
name is the united states of america and
you're going to say listen guys we've
changed
we're nice people now but that's not
what we don't just we don't you know we
don't want to do any of this anymore
let's just kind of kick it in
let's have a good relationship together
and let's do this say you change
say we change philosophically
dramatically to go to a libertarian
philosophy
i see the only way that works if
everybody is joining that camp china's
gonna say you're good for you guys go
ahead russia's gonna say
okay awesome nice people uh your current
system means in about four to eight
years new guy's gonna take over what
you're doing right now and he's going to
go back to whatever was in the past
before the dystopian future is happening
now well so you're acting like this is
some future the chinese right now are
dominating us in places like africa and
southeast asia because we are wasting
our time fighting wars in afghanistan
they love
let me just say okay there's two errors
here that you can control for right and
i think you're focusing on one and not
the other and the other is more the
reality of the situation right now so
you can make the argument that if we
kind of back off that that's less of a
disincentive for other people to to take
over because they don't think we're
going to be as forceful strong what's
actually going on more in in reality
right now is that we are provoking a lot
of these other countries into some of
their actions i mean look we expanded
nato all the way up to the russian
border and then we're shipping in money
uh weapons and money and also were
instrumental in a ukrainian coup in 2014
all before vladimir putin ended up in
invading i don't think the lesson here
is necessarily that oh if we back off
he's going to invade we also might
provoke him by going further and i think
this could i agree okay fine so there's
a woman today said that they're
considering uh joining nato right like
this
now now things are escalating higher and
higher rather than what we want which is
to de-escalate the situation okay so on
on top of that look do you honestly
think let's think about this does does
vladimir putin or does china do they
want us out of afghanistan or in
afghanistan for another 20 years they
want to say they want us in for another
20 years they are not looking at what
we've done with this empire and saying
oh great they bankrupted themselves and
destroyed their culture maybe we could
be next on that i think they'd rather
wait china's been going around and
investing with countries while we've
been occupying them militarily we have
made the hugest blunder strategically in
the 21st century of handing the 21st
century to china we need to stop doing
that what we should be doing is saying
yes we're going to pull back we can
trade with people invest with them we're
going to have the freest economy here we
can have and be 100 times richer than
china and they're not something we're
going to have to worry about i'd much
rather go in that direction than in the
direction of look it's like this anytime
i understand you're saying that you're
not advocating for us provoking them
you're talking about how do we make sure
that we defend but once you create this
entrenched power
this is where it's going to go you know
the old cold warriors back in the day uh
before the fall of the soviet union uh
guys like bill buckley he used to say
you know i basically agree with
libertarians you know in theory but look
we got the soviet union so we have to
have this big military-industrial
complex in his word we in his words we
needed a totalitarian bureaucracy within
our own shores just to fight off the
soviet union to fight this cold war and
then when the when the soviet union fell
in 1991 they all went great military
industrial complex over now we can go
back to being a normal country oh no of
course they didn't then they went oh we
got to go see about saddam hussein we
got to go see about kosovo we got to go
see and just wars continued on and on
and on because once you have this
entrenched government power well this is
how they make money this is how they
expand their power so it's not i don't
think you can have it perfectly down the
middle we're this big bad policeman of
the world but we only do good by
everyone it's too corrupting this is
what the founders all said this is why
we can't go around the world looking for
monsters to slay we have to stay here 90
of the world is in really bad shape it's
not what first world people live like
and i think you know that it's not that
is a sad difficult reality but the best
thing we can be is be a city on a hill
be an example to these other countries
let them learn from us if we're richer
and happier and more prosperous and more
free other countries will try to emulate
us we can enforce it at the barrel of a
gun and it's not gonna work and stop
subsidizing our threats well that's for
sure whether it's the cia funding the
next terror group that we haven't even
heard of yet like they did with isis
like they did with al qaeda whether it's
uh uh whether it's like we're talking
about subsidizing essentially
subsidizing the economies of of russia
and china uh through bad uh regulatory
and tax uh structures here that make it
harder to do business here uh whether
it's i mean
what started with the middle east
operation ajax eisenhower because he
didn't like the democratically elected
uh government that was in iran uh he
replaced it he did operation ajax which
was the cia going in and deposing the
democratically elected government
replacing it with the shah who was very
unpopular right and so he comes in and
comes back in with a vengeance and that
leads to the the uh the um the
revolution yes the iranian revolution
okay so now you have the ayatollahs in
charge
this is what happens
when we're saying what are we going to
do about it what we should do about it
is look at how we got here and then how
we can fix it if there were a stop china
from invading any one button i don't
think anyone here wouldn't press it but
there isn't what there is is a
military-industrial complex that has
proven itself really bad at doing things
other than making money for cronies and
corporate interests uh killing lots and
lots of people and making us all less
safe in the process do you think there's
a likely that we're gonna have another
hitler
no
are you seeing in the states or or in
the world no no worldwide not not in the
states do you think there's a likelihood
that there will be
possibly another hitler i think it's
unlikely i mean there's there's it's not
impossible look i think you have three
figures in the 20th century who kind of
rise to that level of evil uh in uh
hitler stalin and mao yeah and um so the
idea of having another one of them
i think that might be a type of unique
evil that was somewhat unique to that
time in this post-industrialized world
in the in the aftermath of world war one
um it i think it would be much harder to
pull off today in a world where
information travels so much quicker
around the world that doesn't mean it's
impossible and weapons too nuclear
weapons also
i think it is likely i i want to say i
think it is likely and we have to look
at what led to the hitler and stalin and
mao which by the way it wasn't them as
individuals if it hadn't been them it
would have been someone else okay so in
hitler uh we had the weimar republic
which did uh out-of-control spending
also the after-effects of world war one
world war ii was basically an extension
of world war one there was a
what 20-year truce that happened there
but in the in the meantime you had the
allied countries that were just
destroying germany's economy germany's
government was spending money out of
control and it led to the money being
worth absolutely nothing and that
allowed a man mad man like hitler to
come in because he provided a stark
contrast to what everyone else was
saying and that allowed that to happen
and it was our it was also our federal
reserve i mean if you look at in i think
it was in 28 the nazis the nazi party
destroyed in the elections in germany
then they came back again in the special
uh election was in in 30 i think i might
have right around these years and they
came back and they took a bunch of power
this was at the nazis gotten power and
it was all because of the great
depression which was caused by our
bubble bursting here that the federal
reserve created and then all of the debt
got called in from germany it destroyed
the german people and of course
enforcing the treaty of versailles as
you said look woodrow wilson in world
war one said we have to make the world
safe for democracy right kind of this
argument yeah we had despots in europe
so we have to go there and overthrow
them and we overthrow that you know the
the kings and queens the monarchs are
all gone in europe and england in name
only but the monarchs are gone in
england and then in the aftermath of
world war one you got adolf hitler
vladimir lenin and joseph stalin and
those monarchs looked pretty good
at that point well i want to bring out
one quick point though i'm not against
fighting
i'm marine i'm not afraid of violence
i'm trained to be
tons of my brothers and sisters have
gone over there and lost arms and legs
but my worry is why am i marines leaving
their legs in the streets of i don't
know kandahar or baghdad if i'm gonna
leave my legs in the streets in the
streets of manhattan i'll fight for my
city i'll fight for my country i'll
fight for my nation not afraid of that
but why are we sending literally
millions of men and women to go fight
overseas and when they come back we
treat them like garbage anyway and then
we don't even know why they die they
don't know why their lives are ruined
this is not the right answer right if
they're gonna die
and i'm telling i know these people they
would lay their life down and when i was
a marine i would have ordered men to
their death or i would have gone to my
death because ronald reagan who was my
first man in chief would have told me to
do so and many of them would have would
do it but why are we doing it in for in
in afghanistan literally for nothing
in iraq literally for nothing the active
active duty military people uh vote and
send more money to the most anti-war
presidential candidates ron paul ron
paul got more money from active duty
military members than every other
republican combined in 2008 and 2012.
donald trump got far more support from
the military than hillary clinton when
he was taking a more dovish stance in
2016. the people who actually have to
fight these wars are the ones who know
what's up and they don't want to do it
johnson was popular what veterans do
yeah
he got something like double digits
right uh i've been to uh almost all 50
states at this point in just the last
two three years during the campaign and
after the campaign working on on you or
the power and growing that now um
doing that i've met with people across
the country i would say that at any
event that i do
anywhere from 20 to 40 percent of the
people that come out are either active
duty or veterans who are coming that
what brought them into libertarianism
was either me or someone else dave or or
larry or ron paul or whoever else
telling them that we were against the
wars of intervention we were against the
military-industrial complex we were
against the veterans administration uh
single it's not even single-payer
government-run healthcare system that's
that's completely destroying their
health the health that they were
promised when they came back um
that's what's bringing them to it this
system isn't working it makes us less
safe it wastes a bunch of money it
scores countless scores of people are
dying overseas many more are coming here
and dying their uh veterans are people
are going over uh active duty troops are
go over there and dying the ones that
are fortunate enough to come home not in
a flag draped casket come home with ptsd
traumatic brain injuries all sorts of
health problems they're given the worst
form of health care in this country the
veterans administration uh one out of
every 10 homeless people is homeless one
out of every 10 people in this video or
it's a veteran whatever every 10
homeless people is a veteran one out of
every 10 uh prisoners is a veteran is
actually higher than that now and this
is as a direct result of this system so
when we're saying do something yes we
should do something and that something
is looking at the root cause of what
even caused a communist regime to be
powerful in the first place and stop
doing that yeah so for for uh jessica do
you have anything to say here because
we're about to take a shot at tequila
after this because i think
oh i'm ready for tequila okay all right
good so adam if you want to start
so let me let me finish let me finish
this and i want to hear what you say
here so this is this is what i'm uh
getting from what you guys are saying
okay
uh military industrial complex check we
don't disagree
most of the wars started that we didn't
need to go to they were not necessary
fine check 90 let's put it out you can
say 100 percent fine they were not
necessary let's go there the only area
for me with this that concerns me that i
think the argument
uh uh
needs to be sold in a better way is
you have to believe that there are
certain people worried
and and fearing the next possible
you know hitler that decides to go out
there and do something i think your
argument has to touch on that a little
bit to know that here's how we would
handle that person i'm i'm a
strategist i'm a defense guy i'm an
insurance guy i'm a financial guy so
it's always a defensive strategy in case
of a market crash if the market like
right now inflation's about to go up the
goldman sachs we had a meeting with them
last week saying six did the last time
the interest rates went up twice in a
span of a quarter three months um we had
a recession within uh uh 24 months 60
chance there's been a recession but
we're in a recession right now we're
about to go through it home property
value is going to drop you guys are
seeing what's going on with crypto
what's going on with bitcoin what's
going with ethereum you can't keep doing
this they raised at a half a point in
the highest in the last four decades
this time is coming so how are we
prepared for it right this isn't oh
we're never going to have another
recession oh we're never going to have
another depression that's naive no it's
coming we're never going to have another
hitler we have to think not we have to
say there's going to be one we have to
say if there is
that's the only part i'm saying if a
country like a china or russia decides
to go out there and impose on around
their neighbors what are we going to be
i guess the the point that i think i i
was trying to get at before and i think
this is a bitter pill for a lot of
americans to to swallow
um
that if you're looking for someone
that's us right now yeah that's why
we're the ones who have been there i
mean if you want to talk about the blood
that vladimir putin has on his head they
make this huge deal about when he
invaded crimea you know many people died
when he invaded crimea six
six people died in the invasion of
crimea now in ukraine there have been it
looks like tens of thousands of people
dying and that's twenty three thousand
of his own people
it's horrible it's inexcusable i'm like
the most anti-war person on the planet
i'm not making any excuse for that
however it's just like
look
it doesn't always have to be hitler
exactly but there can be very very bad
people who kill a lot of people that was
a pretty unique thing hitler you like
gassing children and stuff that was
a unique evil maybe the most evil thing
in history but if you're looking at who
is the great evil right now
objectively speaking
we're sitting on the other side of this
this equation which is i think a bitter
pill to swallow from the inside of the
empire so my my perspective on that is
just like
look we got it like let's work on
rolling that evil back if there is a
hitler that rises up outside of the
united states of america some evil
person then yeah i agree with you there
should be contingencies in mind we
should be thinking about what can we do
to kind of have the whole world unite
against this unique evil if that were to
arise however the my only point that i
keep kind of you know harping on is that
we're probably we are definitely the
closest to that right now not us our
federal national government um and
this has been sold by
always invoking this guy's the next
hitler saddam hussein was the next
hitler and then gaddafi was the next
hitler and then assad is the next hitler
and then every single war that they want
they always tell you this guy is the
next hitler so i am just more concerned
i think in reality it's much more of an
issue the blood that our country has on
its hands right now and the fact that
this obsession with finding the next
hitler leads to claiming people who
could nev like the idea that that
gaddafi after decades of ruling this
country was about to go hitlerian
genocidal was complete nonsense and it's
basically been demonstrated at this
point that all the intelligence on that
was wrong and look at the result of that
you put qaddafi and putin in the same
camp that putin's not capable of doing
that no putin is
more capable yes they are more capable
than than but to deal with those people
you don't have to have a
military-industrial complex that's my
point if we i don't we're not saying
that though
no one's saying that no no nobody here
is saying that at all so complex to deal
with the next hitler whatever that next
hitler is no you can do it without the
military industrial complex hitler
stalin and mao were
hitler was a right-wing reactionary was
part of was the leader of a right-wing
reactionary movement stalin and mao were
leaders of the left-wing reactionary
movements actually lenin was and then
stalin took over but but mao was in
charge of the left-wing reactionary
movement in china these are reactions to
bad systems it wasn't like everything
was going great in those countries and
then mean old hitler stalin and mao
showed up where minol uh stop
lenin uh hitler and mao showed up
we have to look at what leads to these
things happening and then fix that this
is like going to a doctor and you have
cancer and they go oh well you see you
got to burn there on your skin we're
going to deal with that well the burns
being caused by a cancer a systemic
problem that needs to be fixed and if
you don't deal with the cancer then
you're just going to keep dealing with
symptoms until the patient dies right we
have these are symptoms hitler was not
the problem he was a symptom of a
problem and what stalin and mal were not
the symptoms they were the symptoms of
that problem the problem is a system
that benefits a very small handful of
people by design at everyone else's
expense that's why and that's why
libertarians focus so much on the
federal reserve and on the central
banking system and on things like that
it's that that leads to those yeah and
look even with the worst of all of them
mao tang right i mean he has more deaths
on his hands than adolf hitler and
joseph stalin combined and look
richard nixon went over to china and
shook his hand and pat buchanan the most
right-wing you know guy you could think
of was writing speeches for him he said
pat buchanan literally said uh in his
book that he was making himself nauseous
and because he was nixon's speechwriter
as he had to write these nice things
about mao say i mean imagine writing
nice things about the the most worst
human being who's ever existed on the
planet you know and but he did that and
that opened up relations and that was
better you know if i was thinking about
how to deal with a country like china or
like uh north korea or something like
that i'd be almost down for some like
gorilla private organization to be like
we're smuggling dvds yes and like
internet hot spots into this country to
open it up so that's what they're
terrified of that's what north korea is
terrified of they're smuggling dvds from
from south korea and they start seeing
the south korean soap operas and they go
why do they have so much food on their
plates
you've been telling us we're richer than
them why i've never seen this much food
you know what i mean it's like that's
the like the question becomes like to
spike's point what caused this cancer
and then what like what is the cure for
it yeah yeah yeah and then for it isn't
military confidence they said the
downfall of the uh ussr wasn't anything
militarily it was freaking blue jeans
yeah that's right and movies it was that
out and really what is that that is a
result of the fact that our economic
system of capitalism even the kind of
corrupt capitalism that we had was
superior to their economic system and
that they ultimately wanted a good life
like americans were having right how
much so does everyone how much longer
after karl marx wrote his book communist
manifesto we had a country
that was a communist country running on
his philosophies about 50 years right
yeah 50 years 45
okay about 50 years of that so nolan
came out in 71 it is now
2022. so
50 yours and
there's not there's not one country for
libertarian time and the only ones you
can say maybe new zealand's got an
element of it but not necessarily fully
there so why why hasn't a
if this philosophy is so effective and
so peaceful and so necessary and so free
why hasn't one of these countries chosen
to take it up as their that does their
you know way of running their country
well here's what as milton friedman
right as
someone you're a fan of i mean he would
say it this way right that if you want
to look look the united states of
america between the end of let's say
take the end of the civil war to about
1910. so about 1865 to 1910. in this and
i'm not saying everything was perfect
back then i'm not saying it was a
libertarian society but economically
speaking looking at it there was no
central bank there was no income tax
there was essentially no federal
regulation of the economy the national
spending was something like two percent
of the national income by today's
standards you'd be like this is
basically anarchist there's literally no
government intervention and in this time
period we had the largest at the time
expansion of wealth the biggest
improvement in the lot in life of the
average man in the history of the world
there's the wealth that had never been
thought of before was created now the
problem that i think freedom has is that
uh also a milton friedman quote he goes
you know freedom is in the general
interest but it's not in anybody's
special interest here's the issue and so
what happens is as the wealth gets
created more and more the government
tends to siphon off it the parasitical
class tends to siphon more and more and
more and this grows the government and
so this is the issue that we've been
dealing with it's like because we're the
richest country in the world it was
because we were the most free country in
the world we become the richest country
in the world because we're the richest
country in the world we now have the
largest tax base this leads to the
government getting bigger and bigger and
now we have the largest government in
the world the largest most powerful
government in the history of humanities
the united states federal government so
that is the challenge but it's not as if
no countries maybe no country has
embraced the entire libertarian program
that's also true for marxism it's not as
if any country really embraced every
single word he ever wrote um but the
countries who have embraced more freedom
have been the most the most successful
countries in the world um so we just i i
think my view for what the solution is
to that is to create as much of a
libertarian populist uprising as we can
have yeah i think the more people that
believe in these values the more
libertarians there are the more likely
we are to live in a different
libertarian and independent
uh well i think libertarian is a
philosophical outlook whereas
independent just means you are not part
of one of these two you know what i mean
or any major parties or any of the
parties one's a political affiliation so
you can visual philosophy i mean you
could be both a libertarian and an
independent or you could be a member of
the libertarian party and an independent
thinker but an independent could just be
something different than what the
establishment is whereas we are
something specific people who believe in
human liberty and the reason that a lot
of independents aren't coming to the
libertarian party and for that matter a
lot of
most self-described libertarians aren't
members of the libertarian party so for
example uh one of the best ways you can
judge if someone's a libertarian or not
is how they register in their voting in
most states the difference between
registered libertarians in states that
have party registering or have third
party registering and members of that
state party is 99
yes
it's like one percent of not and i'm not
talking about the population of the
state i'm saying people that have
already identified as libertarians are
not joining the party and the reason is
and i think this is what you're saying
you're you're not asking from a from a
philosophical standpoint you're saying
why are people not becoming libertarians
and i think the answer is because our
focus has been wrong we talk all the
time about what libertarians are going
to do for the wars what we're going to
do for health care what we're going to
do in dc and with the federal reserve
and those are good things to talk about
but long before the vast majority of
people who actually decide who is in
office decide to give us a shot they
want to see how we're going to deal with
things in their backyard i'm trying to
no i know you are and the reason that i
coming out of the campaign the reason i
that i started you are the power is
because we're doing exactly that
localized grassroots single issue
activism show people what libertarianism
looks like as policy how it actually
looks like in practice instead of these
great theories i can come in here and
sell you the best idea possible but if
it never happens then it makes just as
much sense for me to say you know the
way we're going to deal with china is by
me throwing magic thunderbolts at them
and then that'll fix it with the
likelihood of us winning the presidency
right now i might as well give that
answer it makes more sense for our main
focus to be on where we're actually
already winning sometimes despite
ourselves which is at the local level
which grows us as a party it shows
people that we aren't this you know
utopian pipe dream it's actual common
sense feasible things that can be done
and we can build up from there and we
build the infrastructure because not
only when the rock converts to
libertarianism will he be able to win
because we have the structure in place
but he'll want to in the first place
instead of just joining one of the other
parties and trying to change it from the
inside which never happens that's a
that's a scam there but the the reason
that they would do that is because right
now we don't have much to offer them so
we have to build from the ground up and
if we don't do that then we're going to
be here 50 years later talking about in
theory how ending the federal reserve
would end our 400 inflation rate in 2018
after i won ballot access and party
status for my for my party libertarian
party in new york across the state again
in 2019 after i had lost but i by the
way to your point there were 7 000
registered libertarians in new york
state in 2018 i got 100 000 votes he's a
prototype of what i'm talking about
exactly that's why i'm exactly what he
said so then after that i crossed the
state again and in 2019 we had 107
victories at the local level we went
from zero libertarians to 107 in one
year and then the state afterwards
decided oh yeah we're going to change
the rules on how you can get in the
ballot so now we couldn't get the ballot
anymore you might say what does that
mean most people don't realize getting
on the ballot just being on a ballot so
you can have a choice to vote for me
costs hundreds of thousands of dollars
takes massive amount of people are going
to back you came in the ballot when the
people independents came to me with tons
of money and said larry we want to run
as independent in 2022 people ask me
that was 20 22 20 20 i'm sorry 2020 what
about independent i said great you're
gonna have to have 40 million dollars
and you probably won't be able to get in
all of these dates like what so yeah
well we have that money i know you can
raise 50 million dollars but you can't
get through the red tape to be on every
single ballot in 50 states just run
libertarian we've already done that
already they're like we're gonna run
independent you can't if you could run a
dependent there'd be a president
bloomberg right now
it's impossible ballot access is one of
our biggest issues which is why i run to
gain ballot access so people can't on
the ballot and we just got hammered
again in new york state now i got to get
45 000 signatures in six weeks and they
just made new laws that destroyed our
our local um congressional districts so
no congress people can't even get on the
ballot independent because there's no
congressional let me let me ask you they
hammer us this way tell me who is a
major influencer in america today that
has
libertarian tendencies would you put
musk in that category or no no i put
musk in that category rogan in that
category absolutely i put drew carey
who's talks to seniors every day in his
tv you put theo in that category yeah he
feels and i can't i think he's he kind
of like he's certainly very interested
in libertarian ideas i think he he kind
of is somewhere between a populist yeah
and he's a libertarian musk what would
you say musk is musk i think is actually
a left libertarian i think so is rogan i
think both of them are left-leaning
libertarians okay so who has sat down
with these guys to try to get them to
start selling the concept of
libertarians well i'm not rogan i'm
talking mostly yeah i mean rogan's joe's
a good friend of mine um but there's in
terms of i've i'm trying to work on him
to get yes to get peter thiel and those
guys on board but i think that i mean
there's a guy to do that peter thiel i
believe uh donated to ron paul's
campaign um i believe so so i think he's
well aware of these ideas also weirdly
enough uh jack dorsey like tweeted out
uh murray rothbard article man economy
and state which to me is like the
greatest libertarian piece of writing
and he's a big crypto bitcoin yeah he's
kind of in that world but then but i
don't i don't doubt something i don't
know what his deal is though like
because he's like now he you know he's
like elon musk is right no one should be
kicked off twitter and you're like can i
ask you know you were there for a while
man you could have heard this larry
brought up andrew yang we had andrew
yang what a month ago yeah he literally
backed he's endorsed me i'm literally
back by the forward oh my question okay
so
he's starting this new uh forward
forward okay
that's essentially a competitor
libertarian party no no an ally an ally
it is an ally 100 because they want to
break the duopoly just like we do we are
100 allies okay but aren't you guys
yeah we have heating for votes
but yes we're not competing for votes
but we are allies and crushing duopoly
that's why he realized you can't it's
hard to run within the party right he
realized it amash realized that tosi
gabriel left democratic party i mean
maybe not officially but in reality she
has they're all leaving because they
realize that two participants doesn't
work that's why we're allies we are all
allies it's like when the japanese
invaded uh china right the there were
the maoists and then there were the
chiang kai-shek people they got together
to fight the japanese that's us we're
together to fight the empire oh that
doesn't end very well it doesn't it
doesn't but let's hope we change that we
we learn from our mission the enemy of
my enemy is my friend
so what about the green party we work
together i know howie hawkins how is my
friend we're both marines and by the way
howie hawkins is so far is so far left
we get our guns back he's actually pro
2a he's a real socialist he literally
was he literally was the socialist party
nominee in uh in 2020 and he is my
friend and we are absolute allies is
there enough room for all these parties
that are getting one percent uh if if
you add them all up we get remember new
york state is a plurality state i don't
need 51 of new yorkers i need 35 percent
of those who vote
there are 18 million new yorkers about
12 million eligible to vote 10 million
registered to vote about 6 million
actually vote so if i get about 2
million to 15 million votes i win so i
need about one in eight i don't even i
don't need a majority any one in eight
and i'm gonna larry for the people you
were talking off-camera what how are the
conditions in new york what's happened
in new york the last 10 years oh my god
horrible new york we've lost over 2
million people in the past 11 years to
include this guy right here which makes
me angry but yes we've lost lots of
people from new york they all take off
and they leave and they leave because
we're too oppressive right our
government is so oppressive that it
breaks up families my mother had to
retire and eventually die in south
carolina because she couldn't afford
living in new york state and she left
her grandchildren for that it's terrible
new york state is a basket case where we
now have a budget that went from 170
billion to 220 billion while we're
losing millions of people
that math doesn't work we just keep
raising our budget we just keep making
things harder we keep it making more
rules and regulations we keep crushing
our families and then we wonder why some
realtors are telling me that a thousand
people a day are leaving if you guys
have noticed that you have some much
louder more obnoxious neighbors lately
yeah
i showed you the cover from the wall
street journal about how miami's are
basically up in arms about how much uh
rent has increased florida is red
because of new york right used to be a
swing state but we have exported all of
our republican our red and conservative
voters to florida we made florida a red
state it was a purple state before new
york jessica is there any state worse
than california i mean what's going on
there oh no i had a question for you
about what you think of the recent
development about in new york not even
needing to be a a citizen to vote yeah
it's they they can't do it in federal
elections but they can do it in local
elections that's going to be come into
effect in new york it's a terrible idea
for many reasons but one of them is
because it's only 30 days
which it just it makes it extra bad so
maybe maybe i should go visit so i can
come vote for you you can you should
but yeah show up for 30 days or
something exactly yeah just stay for 31
days and you can then and you can vote
in new york city that's a city thing not
to say thanks to anything can we go to
the next topic borders libertarian come
on borders so i talked to joe by borders
okay
you know let people come in you know
don't worry about it we don't have to
worry about it what is your position
when it comes down to the borders oh
yeah so i have a very different uh
outlook on borders that and there's
there's a big divide there's been a big
split amongst libertarians i'm not an
open borders guy um i i don't believe
that that's the correct libertarian
position um my thing is that like in the
philosophical abstract i don't think
that anybody inherently has a right to
go some to an area that they don't own
or are not invited to and so i think
that probably my ideal situation under
the current paradigm would be something
like a sponsorship system an invitee
system where you basically have to get
an american citizen to vouch for you and
financially kind of you know like back
you in order to come into the country i
don't think that just robes of people
showing up have some inherent right to
be here because they decided they wanted
to um but the current system is bait is
is insane yes i mean we basically we
subsidize if the taxpayer is forced to
subsidize immigration and then the
taxpayer is forced to subsequent
subsidize the war on immigration and
then just everything about it is madness
so the number one thing is that you end
the war on drugs you roll back as much
of the warfare state uh the welfare
state as you can this way you're not
subsidizing people to come in and you
cut down on the black markets and the
smuggling and all of that stuff and all
of the the interventions in uh in latin
america and all of the the dea
operations there where we prop up the
cartels that makes life miserable for
people in those countries and leads to
more floods of of immigration i'd like
to take more steps like that but i am
not on the joe jorgensen idea of like
just i think the idea that under current
situations just opening the borders
tomorrow did you not trust the idea of a
border um i've always had the the kind
of ron paul um conspiratorial skepticism
that i don't like the idea of building
walls i think they could be used to keep
us in and um i like i i don't like walls
on kind of i think really bad
governments tend to build walls and i
don't like that uh but i do think that
it was reasonable that donald trump
stood up for tens of millions of
americans who were like look we do not
like that we have no say in who comes
into our country i think that's a
reasonable position for those people i
don't think it makes them evil racist
for feeling that way you can have
vibrant immigration and secular borders
and this is the policy what we should be
doing for literally six years you build
two ellis islands on a southern border
one may be in texas maybe one in
california these two ellis islands are
controlled by two separate companies and
the companies are private companies and
they're basically recruiting companies
if you want to come to our country you
go to on the ellis islands what you do
you go there and they put you in
quarantine or give you your check-ins
whatever they do they check you out if
you are okay they give you an orange
card in any state that agrees that that
once you brought us this this thing they
send you off to that state to go work we
know that you're working in that state
you check in every two years while
you're there you are not allowed to take
any public assistance at all and you pay
your taxes all you do you you just check
in if you check if you don't check it in
two years we come get you we know where
you are we can get you if you do check
in as long as everything good keep going
another two years you keep going now how
do you pay for that we don't pay for
that they do there's a model that's
already working it's called recruiting
companies recruiters get paid as they
place people right now farms um people
in the hospitality industry restaurants
industries are spending billions of
dollars in the black market to get labor
well don't spend in the black market
just pay these guys they'll get you
workers as much as you want now what up
the people you say well women they're
still bad people yes they won't go to
the ellis islands they'll be along the
border that's what use border patrol for
to get the bad guys this was the only
people starving the deserts aren't
innocent families they're bad guys who
are doing bad things i don't want anyone
to stop in the desert but if anyone's
going to stop in the desert let it be
them and our border patrol without
having to raise any extra money is now
focused only on that well larry what if
one of those those those those uh bell
silence do poorly or hurt people that's
why there's two of them people will go
to the one they want as they're making
money and the market will make it better
and better but it's a bigger piece of
that there's give or take 10 to 12
million people in in america right now
who are undocumented we don't know what
they're doing where they are they can go
to the ellis island too they can pack up
and just go there and go you know what
i'm gonna get i want to become legal
great go to ellis island spend your 30
days get checked out you're good go back
to work work legally when they go back
all of a sudden the rest of the people
in the community go huh so you didn't
get deported no i did my paperwork i pay
my taxes i don't take i don't take any
any um you know public assistance
they're gonna start going too which
makes law enforcement's job easier there
are bad people who come across the
border in our country we can't get them
they're all in enclaves right now and
everyone's scared to say where bad pablo
is but if all of a sudden they're legal
they can call the cops where's pablo
right there don't see him go get him
cops i'm not getting deported he can't
blackmail me anymore so now law
enforcement can do the job you will
watch the the undocumented population
shrink over the course of 10 years
because most would just go get
documented and the bad guys will get
caught this is an actual system that can
work and we can build more of them as
many as people want build a bunch of
them if people want to doesn't matter
but here's the best part if you do that
you now can make a private company
authorized to now give things like green
cards right say over 10 years or
whatever take a test or whatever
whatever rules you want they can start
doing that process through that whether
you speak english or whatever's the
rules you create those rules well that
doesn't affect anybody in line for the
government in fact eventually the
government will probably be worse people
start going to that instead of going
through the government we'll save money
because more people go to rose ellis
islands then go through the government
system this is an actual libertarian
solution the market is stepped in we
don't raise any extra money nourish your
taxes everyone gets better service and
law enforcement is assisted and if you
couple that with what dave was saying
ending the main reasons for these
massive surges to begin with which is
the dea and the cia and other government
agencies through the war on drugs
sponsoring the u.s sponsored cartels to
fight against the russia and
china-sponsored cartels so that they can
take over this country and massacre
anyone that didn't vote for their
candidates that's why they're fleeing
that's why you have i mean think of the
sophie's choice situation that so many
people there are making where they're
sending their children off with
smugglers they don't know knowing the
likelihood of them getting raped and
being sex trafficked them get ending up
in in one of these uh cages i'm sorry
joe biden's president now these shelters
they're not okay they're not they stop
being cages january of 21. but they're
doing that because they know the
likelihood of them staying there is
almost 100 that they'll be killed that's
the kind of problems that are being
caused by the war on drugs when you end
that a lot of these surges aren't
happening and now whatever system we use
whether it's through sponsorship whether
it's through more of an ellis island
style system whatever it is you're not
going to be managing all of the people
that are coming here the current system
we have now the war on drugs and the war
on migration have led to both a bunch of
people who are just trying to flee
violence in cages
or being separated from their families
which by the way is
costing the taxpayer anywhere between
five and eight hundred dollars per day
per person many of them spend months in
there i mean you want to talk about a
welfare system that costs far more than
any welfare system right you've got that
going on you've got this this major
impediment to the flow of goods and
services and people across the borders
including to your point about uh
walls being used the other way
increasingly traffic into mexico is
being stopped by border patrol agents
for national security and drug control
reasons it's for control it's another
way to skim right but so
that's happening and in the midst of all
that there are still millions of people
here illegally including ms-13 members
and all the worst scary people and and
also a lot of people that aren't they
just they there is no legal process for
them to come here so they came here
illegally if you focus on if if you
allow people to come and you have a more
expedited system
then now law enforcement can focus on
actual bad guys like larry and dave boat
said and i can speak on this as someone
who uh my wife when we got married i was
her sponsor to come here the process we
went through that cost thousands of
dollars
did absolutely nothing had my wife been
a terrorist or whatever else nothing
they did
would have stopped her from coming in
they asked her are you a terrorist
no okay are you a communist
no are you they asked her if she was a
nazi my wife is black and i'm jewish
she told them that okay just you know
we're talking good for you right we're
talking about doing something what was
her answer
don't leave us i'm trying to create a
cliffhanger here okay listen i know how
to build up a story so they asked her if
she's a nazi she said i'm black my
husband is jewish do you know what the
response of the people who we have put
in charge are our government is put in
charge of protecting us said well ma'am
uh your husband could be a nazi if you
wanted to he's an american citizen
these are the people when we're saying
we need to protect ourselves from the
bad guy this guy heard i'm black and my
husband's jewish and somehow that made
him think well i get boy he could be a
nazi if he wanted to these are not we're
not sending our best okay when it comes
right now we're not sending our best and
brightest this is another government
program and government programs don't do
a good job at fixing this
we fix this by dealing with the
government interventions that have made
this worse and then whatever is left we
can deal with that through market
through sponsorships through through a
private ellis island system whatever but
do it in a way that now it's not this
massive you know crisis surge you don't
have this humanitarian crisis on the
border you don't have children in cages
you don't have millions of people here
illegally including uh gang members and
everything else and if there's any shot
that they have of stopping bad guys from
getting in here it's going to be from
them focusing on the people who are the
most likely to be the bad guys because
coming here for the right reasons is
easy and able to be done
so you guys are on the same page on this
top
board more or less i mean like we have
we have slight differences probably
between all three of us but i do i do
think that really like right what we all
probably agree on is that right at the
heart of this is a war on drugs issue i
mean the major problem that you have at
the border is the the gang element of it
the criminal element of it the drugs
that are being smuggled in the crime
that's associated with that and much
like you know when when we tried a
prohibition that all of a sudden it was
like there was this criminal gang mob
element that rose up with it now
after repealing prohibition the murder
rate dramatically fell the crime rate
dramatically fell now alcohol still is a
problem i mean alcohol isn't great and
there are people who abuse it there are
people who ruin their lives over it
there are people who are get very
violent when they're on it it's relate
like there's a bunch of problems with it
but you don't have the gang criminal
problem still associated with alcohol
because it's legalized and likewise that
would happen with these other drugs as
well that doesn't mean there's no
problems associated with it you know
like everything in life is trade-offs
there's costs and benefits to everything
it's just that the costs are far worse
of black markets and prohibition than
they are of legalization which which
government institution like who where
where does the government get things
right
that's a tough one when it fails to
intervene
i i want to say something here if when
it comes to government like would this
be border patrols that are working for
the government is this who would be on
the board
so you need the border patrol that's a
government agency i'm not saying we you
heard me say i'm not about abolish
everything immediately i'm about to
create institutions that are private and
community to give the support we need
then government institutions will either
get better i can't see how but they
might or they'll begin to go away
because other communities something
better correct something better will
step up but we have to create an
environment as long as government
monopolizes everything we're not able to
have community support and then that's
my issue if we set this is why i like
the the elvis island private idea
because eventually what will happen
immigration could be controlled by
privatized companies who know what
they're doing compete against each other
to make sure they do things right we
won't require a government eventually
they'll want to patrol their own they'll
begin to do this on their own if we
create about an environment the problem
i have is most people want a 30 second
10 second solution that's magical these
are systemic issues that will take 10
years to repair but we've got to set the
ball in motion that's the key government
is driven by a high time preference that
they have helped to create they have
helped through government schooling to
teach everyone that there's this
terrible thing that's happening because
we're letting you do this we're not
going to let you do any more we have a
magic fix that's going to fix it oops
that didn't fix it it made it worse we
need more control and it's an endless
cycle we saw this with covid we've seen
this with terrorism we've seen it with
everything now the problem is
if you don't have something to replace
it with
then ultimately it's either this or
nothing now sometimes nothing's better
but there's something better than
nothing which is something that would
actually fix that problem perfect
example bitcoin cryptocurrency how much
easier is it us first to sell people on
ending central banking because there's
something already in place if there
wasn't we'd be and they said well what
are you going to replace the federal
reserve with well it's going to work out
the market will fix it that just saying
that to the average person you're
basically saying to them or what they
hear is i don't really care i care more
about my ideas than your well-being and
i'm super smart and i'm trying to tell
you that that's what the market will fix
this sounds like you have the market if
the market can fix this then let's use
the market to fix it which is why again
we need to focus more on okay
identifying the problem okay here's the
problem and here's how it was created or
made worse by government but then also
here is a solution that is outside of
government
so that government now to larry's point
can either compete with that or just not
do it anymore let's talk about what
government is for a second government is
at its core a monopoly that is enforced
with violence financed by theft now
whatever whether you think government's
necessary not necessary whether you can
whatever you consider yourself let's
just take a step back on what government
actually is
now let's ask this question if you were
going to come up with the best way to
provide a service
would you settle on a monopoly that is
financed by uh theft and enforced by is
that where you'd like to get your
chicken sandwiches from is that where
you'd like to get your health care from
is that where you'd like to get
different things that you need from a
company that can do whatever it wants to
you and does not have to provide you
with any value and and the only reason
that you're even using them in the first
place is because you have no other
option and they will punish you if you
don't no
but we also can't say well we don't need
government we can just do it ourselves
we have to actually do it ourselves and
provide actual feasible solutions and
when possible with with borders not so
much you'd have to actually have
government policy to to bring in things
like the ellis island or whatever but
outside of that like for example
cryptocurrency the blockchain mutual aid
working together on the ground you can
actually come up with real feasible
solutions that work so that instead of
me having to have this long high-minded
philosophical first principles
discussion about how libertarianism is
going to work i can just say this
that fixed it
it's literally what i'm doing it's why
every time you ask me a question i said
i will give you a policy yeah i you may
not have liked my answer but i gave you
an answer every single time i didn't
fall back to ideology didn't fall back
to concepts i said we will do this every
single time that's why people are
following me because i give them actual
answers at the end of joe rogan's show
if anyone watches it by the way episode
1167 if anyone happens to just want to
watch it at the end of that episode he
said larry i love your ideas where'd
they come from i said well me and my
team we put them together we put
policies together he goes you better
lock those things down i said why he
said people will take them i said take
them i don't have to run then i can go
back to my business take the take it fix
the country fix my state i'll go home
i'll have to do this i got stuff to do i
got a family i got friends i'll go do
that instead so i'm about policy that's
what i'm all about if we have better
policies people to your point will just
go yeah that makes sense spike keep that
larry davies 2024 who who who would you
like to see be the leading candidate or
the nominee for
uh libertarian party representing the
libertarian party uh
no i'm kidding no uh i i really think we
need you brought her back you said don't
say the name i was teased she heard it
though she's watching don't that
coming after you i happen to agree with
the idea of somebody popular that to me
matters tremendously somebody popular do
you have a name i would take someone
like a drew carey because he know he's
he talks to people who vote his audience
is literally voters right he does the
the price is right show right and
they're all like retired seniors so
that's good because they'll vote for him
because they know him but anybody
popular i'm good with that's what i want
someone who is popular i'm in
okay dave
someone really great so i don't have to
do it would be uh good maybe the rock
you have anyone got his number here
would you can you just would you
consider it because i know they're
throwing your name in there constantly
yeah well i have a lot of people in my
camp within the libertarian world who
want me to do it and i've kind of been
open and saying that i'd consider uh
doing it but like if there was i like
kind of in the spirit of what larry said
i really love my career i really love my
family i got two little kids if someone
else could do a really great job at it
that'd be awesome i'd be happy to to do
that but i do think that we have the
reason why i joined the libertarian
party uh is because i think this party
has a real opportunity particularly in
the current political landscape in
america and it's been frustrating to me
to watch the presidential candidates get
this
golden opportunity to really i'm not
saying they could win the presidency
obviously that's where many steps off
from that but to really change the
narrative force the other two parties to
have to talk about the issues that we
care about open up tens of millions of
americans minds to a whole different way
to look at how we organize a society
legally and politically i've seen that
opportunity and i feel like i know what
they should be doing with that
opportunity and um if no one else is
going to do it then i probably that
would be i would i would i'm 39 so i'd
be uh 42 or 41. everyone yeah he's
popular i would support him too anyone
who's popular i want to support not only
that he sells it very i need someone
he's a libertarian
that should be i mean libertarian you
got to be libertarian yes and popular if
you're libertarian and popular i'm in so
question do you have anybody you'd like
to see peter thiel peter thiel okay i
don't know if he would do i think he's
more of a i don't know if he's a
candidate type i think he's more the guy
you want to he's a king
yeah he's behind a closed spike did you
want to go yeah so if you if you had to
pick the four people that are asked the
most if they're going to run for the
nomination it's the three of us and
justin amash but likely i would think i
i don't think i'm missing anyone there
um and what i say when i'm asked that is
that uh pretty much a lot of the things
that they've said that it needs to be
someone who is able to uh excite people
who is able to demonstrate that they
actually can do things and provide
solutions someone that is an actual
libertarian i think that is obviously
important uh and someone who is popular
and has a magnetic personality and can
bring people in i also say i don't that
i don't even really care right now who
our nominee is right now we are talking
about who the next person is to go and
score the margin of error
the reason i started you were the power
is because i want one day for our
presidential candidate in 24 28 whenever
whether it's one of us or someone way
better than us
to actually have a shot of winning and
in the meantime before we get to this
utopian future where libertarians take
over the world and leave everyone alone
that's something we like to say is
actually show
how actually help people now there are
people suffering under the abuses and
excesses of government from the federal
level all the way down to the local
level which is actually where most
tyranny happens is your city council
your county council your state
government now
help them now build coalitions with
people now bring them into the movement
now i am like these two i've been
retired since 2017. i'd like to go back
to being retired i say i'm retired now
it just means i don't get paid i do way
more now than i did when i was working
full-time when i had my businesses but i
would like to go back and enjoy
retirement spend time with my wife too
young to be retired we gotta i'm 39 too
oh dude you're too young to be retired
right we got we got to put that talent
to use for 30 more years you can enjoy
the time with your family
oh my god
but here's the thing i would like to
from a from a political standpoint yeah
not have to do this because we have
built something up that's someone way
more popular than any of us is involved
you know what i like
you know what i'd like to see happen
here's what i like to see happen folks
if you're watching this you're
libertarian
go tack musk non-stop today okay with
this
i'd love to see a meeting between the
main voices of libertarians with rogan
and musk just sit down and let musk
destroy you guys in any questions he's
gonna ask you and then if he gets to a
point where he says this [ __ ] makes
sense
then for him to go and do what he did
with the trolling stuff with dogecoin
and bitcoin and crypto and all this
other stuff
all of a sudden everybody's talking
about it next thing you know you got a
bigger platform the next time you're
running but if you got those two guys
backing you up it's big the other thing
i think that another person that may be
a i know you keep talking about drew
carey i i i i there's something special
about vince vaughn him too
i don't know how interested he was in
like really being like the the kind of
because it hurts his business yeah
he is but i agree with you completely i
i also think that right now there's a
really unique thing that's going on
that's really revolutionary that i'm not
sure any of us exactly understand even
those of us who are kind of in the world
but shows like this
and like rogan and tim poole and like a
whole bunch of these other shows that
are like really popular like far more
people are watching this than are
watching the traditional corporate press
and there's this kind of network of all
of these people where a lot of really
powerful wealthy really influential
people are listening to these shows
there's something there where
libertarians now we used to complain for
years that we were kind of denied access
they wouldn't have ron paul on cnn
they'd black him out and all this now we
have this whole alternative
like outlets where we can get on and
talk about the ideas we want to talk
about and we've really got to be good at
utilizing that that's why that's a lot
of like my focus the bitcoining of media
yeah decentralization of media the fact
that we can get out here and talk
whatever the hell we want to say and not
have to deal with the corporate
overlords that are uh condemning what
you're saying and if you get on cnn
which like i've been on on cnn and fox
news and these places before it's
ridiculous they're kind of you get like
like 90 seconds maybe to like answer a
complex problem you get three hours here
yeah
i'm
i don't know if you noticed i had to
step out but but i want to bring up
something important you mentioned when
it comes to running all right and i'm
going to be selfish for a moment i'm
running in new york state this year
we should be more worried about people
running this year because the impact we
make this year
is going to affect 2024 i'm in new york
state if i just come in a tight third
people will notice me i come in second
and beat the republican because my
state's three to one democrat republican
right so republicans never going to win
the question is who comes in second
right so if i come in second that rocks
my my state my state becomes a
multi-party democracy overnight changes
everything if i win with 35 of the vote
new york state goes from blue to gold
that changes the entire nation let me
ask you right now let me ask you let me
ask you a crazy question here uh uh
which which policies which philosophy
makes more sense libertarian or
socialism
let me let me ask one more hang on
let me ask a question a different way
what is the more marketable yep
philosophy to sell libertarian or social
100 it's a great point generally
speaking the left does very well with
socialism because it sounds great the
rhetoric is
amazing suck listening you know packs
the reason we're all going to be happy
we're all going to it's all going to be
fair explain the success of aoc in your
districts over there it sounds amazing
so they're right when it comes to
rhetoric the socialists are very good at
that they're good at saying everyone's
going to be fair everyone's going to be
safe everything all the rich fantasy
it is and it feels good i think it does
go well which is why you don't hear me
talk about libertarianism i talk about
solutions only just solutions i want the
person in front of me to go oh if
they're republican you're republican if
they're democrat you're a democrat
that's what i want them to do i don't i
don't push philosophy you didn't hear me
push philosophy here all i talk about is
here's my solution i'm a candidate a
candidate has to have they ask you a
question but are you republican or
democrat what do you say i would say
independent libertarian independent
libertarian is your answer that's what i
say how much how much door knocking are
you doing me person not that much i'm
not shaking hands i'm i'm not knocking
on doors i'm out in events literally how
many events are you doing how many
events are you doing um just
i'm not when i'll i'll go back i'll do
three tomorrow
two on sunday i'm two on saturday three
on sunday
so far none scheduled for monday but i
do probably 15 a week 15 events a week
give or take and the average audience is
what how many how many people are low
end i'll get three or four high and i'll
get a couple hundred okay got it so
you're on that area you're hustling
you're going you're going after the
house you're doing your product okay
i've got to get 45 000 signatures that
are legal which means i have to get 60 i
understand so so you can make sure that
works so you transitioned where i was
going and you brought it more to present
today which as a great marketer that
means you're you're good at doing that
as well that's good what i will say is
the following but you also about an hour
and a half ago you said in order for me
to do this i got to get registered and i
need this much money to be able to do
this this this that's okay great
if
i
am
hustling today
i would be so proactive to get in front
of five influencers
to get them to put up money and say okay
great guess what here's 10 million bucks
yeah here's 20 million bumps
there's two things and i'm talking an
influencer and i understand what you're
saying because it's federal this is more
state so you have to go more but if if
that guy does it
on the national level the local people
are now saying if so so now your
presentation becomes did you guys say
rubble mustad what here's my mustang no
way yeah
seriously yeah here's one [ __ ] i'm in
okay what do we need here's what we need
to do we need to get a more new york
phones
what you're saying i'm literally doing
andrew yang endorsed me right so i am
getting bigger fixtures but the problem
is most people aren't backing me yet you
know why they don't think i can get in
the ballot so why in the world would you
back me throw money and i've already
raised six figures like i've already
raised six figures already so i'm
already raising money so i do raise
money but why would you if i go hey
patrick give me uh forty thousand
dollars and you go why you're not gonna
be in the ballot you're right i gotta
get in the ballot first when i get in
the ballot and you go oh you're gonna be
on the ballot okay larry let me let me
write you a check but there's also
amount of money i can give i've got to
create a pack then if i want to get more
than forty thousand dollars so there's
limitations how much money i can even
take my average donation in in 2018 was
85
i raised half a million dollars and my
average donation was 85 dollars
so what's that number 85 times half a
million how many people i don't know how
much that is it's a thousand would be 85
000 so 10 000 would be eight fifty so
you have like seven thousand seven
thousand people but i had a couple big
heavy hitters had a couple of those who
gave me like 30 20. it doesn't matter
but you got six thousand so some of them
give you five bucks 10 right which is
great did you guys see what happened
with the musk with the fed yesterday and
twitter do you guys read that story or
no what the fed fed investigating elon
musk oh yeah i heard about this that
open investigation into illamasqua if
you make it a little bit bigger to read
it u.s government has reportedly opened
an investigation to musk's business
dealing surrounding his recent 44
billion dollar purchase of twitter the
sec is probing musk's tardy submission
of public that investors must file when
they buy more than five percent of a
company's shares the disclosure
functions as an early sign to
shareholders and companies that a
significant investor could seek to
control or influence a
company so he was late 10 days which mo
believed to save 140 million dollars
because the price could have been higher
if the public knew about his ownership
five percent the company the case is
easy it's straightforward danny the
university of pennsylvania accounting
professor said but whether they're going
to pick that battle with elon is another
question so you're already seeing how
scared people are of this guy owning
twitter they're losing the uh so go to
associate press yesterday i i don't know
if you guys saw what ap said yesterday
about musk with uh pulled that up about
the fact that here's a
elon musk who is fighting for
freedom of uh
speech but at the same time he was a
person that targeted no not targeted his
attacked a lot of people uh on twitter
and do you want that guy to be the
leader of it's a very it doesn't even
make sense
the idea that that's a contradiction
that he's like look this guy believes
you should be able to say whatever you
want on twitter but also he says
whatever he wants on twitter it's like
there's no contradiction there they're
just look everybody's freaking out
because basically what happened with the
the rise of the internet and social
media is that the establishment lost
their monopoly on information this is
why they were all freaking out for years
and this culminated in donald trump
being elected president in 2016 where
the entire corporate press was telling
you you're not allowed to support this
guy and then 63 million americans were
like no we're going to and so the
response to it then was that they the
congress
hauled all the heads of the social media
companies in front of congress
explicitly threatened them that if they
didn't crack down on fake news and hate
speech they were gonna regulate them and
all of this they basically got them to
all roll over and this led to like this
kind of censorship regime on social
media where basically people get kicked
off and this was really useful to them
during the covet stuff i mean all of the
doctors who were like against the
lockdowns and against the mandates that
challenging the vaccines they all got
banned we had robert malone on and yeah
mcculloch
and these guys these guys and then of
course they went after rogan when he had
malone on like he's always he's already
right
misinformation guy so now you have this
guy this the richest man in the world
who's saying well i'm gonna buy maybe
not the biggest but certainly one of the
most influential social media companies
and i'm saying no no more of these rules
so they're all freaking out about it but
it got announced right after when he
bought uh when he first bought into
twitter that they were looking at um
investigating tesla now they're looking
at investigating this deal yeah now the
federal government's going to crack down
on him because he's committing the crime
of threatening
to allow american citizens to
communicate with each other
it's really bonkers
that's a tweet right there if you pull
it down a little bit so they can see the
logo above elon musk boasts that he's
acquiring twitter to defend freedom of
speech but he has long used the platform
to attack attack
those who disagree with you yes no that
would be an example of people saying
what they want
like like what david said
let this is a again a symptom of a much
bigger problem which is that government
has been using corporations to control
what people can say so that they have
some like degree of separation oh we're
not censoring you it's a private company
that's doing it well now here's someone
saying okay i'm gonna buy the private
company they're like no no no no no you
can only do that if you do what we say
that you do well that means government's
controlling it and taking an even
further step back this is in big tech
this is a marriage of the state of
government and big businesses
that's fascism
that's literal that is the you know
fascism gets thrown around a lot fascism
is when truckers right like fact fascism
is everything now fascism is you know uh
disagreeing with the status quo fascism
actually in many cases is the status quo
and certainly when it comes to big tech
you have a small handful of companies
that in exchange for doing what the
government says they get the carve outs
they get the subsidies they get the the
the licensing the permitting and all of
that because there's such a high barrier
to entry that was created by the crony
class this is a perfect example we are
all hinging on whether one person can
buy one platform to finally let us speak
to each other on the internet because
there's not decentralization because
government did that and then any time
even uh uh this was either earlier no it
was last year or no it was last year
that uh mark zuckerberg who for the most
part has gone along with whatever
government has said on on you know terms
of service and and community standards
and all of that uh but apparently he
wasn't being quite strong enough on on
you know people being skeptic about you
know the vaccine mandates and so joe
biden and jen saki basically just both
came straight out and said yeah no he's
killing people people are going to die
if he doesn't do this well
joe biden is president because uh
twitter censored the hunter biden laptop
i mean that wasn't was a big part
that was a big deal and and then
two weeks ago but that's right and
that's the other thing that gets like so
lost as they're creating this uh
ministry of information or whatever at
the department of homeland security here
is that on so many of these issues the
censoring side which has always
represented the powerful has been wrong
i mean like the the most dangerous
coveted misinformation that was spread
over the last two years was prob i mean
if i had to pick two that were clearly
the most damaging pieces of
misinformation that were spread one was
that lockdowns contained the spread of
the virus that destroyed the lives of
tens of millions of americans because
they believed this policy or claim to
believe this policy would mitigate the
spread of the virus it did nothing to
mitigate the spread and number two was
the fauchites saying that if you got the
vaccine you couldn't contract or spread
covet i mean if you want to talk about
what actually led to people's how many
people got two doses of the vaccine and
then we're like oh i can't get this now
because i've seen fouchy tell me i can't
get this oh i got the sniffles you know
but it can't be coveted because there's
no way you know i can't get that anymore
so i'm gonna go see my grandmother or
whatever the most dangerous
misinformation didn't come from joe
rogan telling young 25 year olds to be
as healthy as they possibly can
like that's who and then the people who
spread that misinformation have the
nerve to go after him for saying stuff
like that so the people who were
censored were the ones telling the truth
the the
the post story is a great example
whatever you think of that hunter biden
story it was real it was obvious at the
time it was real um and the the people
who were telling the truth about
vaccines and lockdowns and mandates they
all got silence and the ones spreading
the most dangerous misinformation we're
elevated by the establishment it's it's
yuri tyler pull up pull up the hunter
biden story since we're on it just to
kind of bring it up so the audience sees
what happened this is from washington
examiner uh hunter biden and doj could
reach settlement for significant fine
the federal investigation to honor biden
appears
to be coming to a head the justice
department is expected to make a final
decision on whether to bring criminal or
civil charges or try to reach a
settlement that could
include a significant fine in the coming
months said the report which uh noted
that allies at a president prefers
settlement if prosecutors want to press
charges against this 52 year old son
whatever the decision is attorney
general merrick garland will have the
final say the rest of the report
focused on kevin morris a prominent
hollywood attorney who lent more than
two million dollars to biden that went
to paying back taxes and supporting his
family as well as this could turn very
ugly for these guys this is starting to
come out here and it's not going to be
too pretty but it depends on who is i
don't know if you saw yesterday i got a
message from james o'keefe from project
veritas did you see who they had the
whistleblower from fbi did you guys see
the fbi whistleblower last night at 11
o'clock no this is crazy so it's an fbi
agent who's the whistleblower and they
put the screen on him and it's black
that you can't tell he's wearing a
hoodie because he doesn't know who it is
and the voice is all distorted but he's
talking about what their model is he's
talking about how why they came after
you james why they're going after
different organizations even though
that's not the job of the fbi but now
they're targeting people and we would
talk about it he's giving the game plan
of what happened so an fbi who's an
organization that was supposed to be
good for you and i with j edgar hoover
now is bullying regular people just
because they're saying something that
the government doesn't want you they
weren't so good during j edgar hoover
and they were pressuring private
companies to do the bulk of the
censoring and by the way there's one
that's happening right now uh and it's
through censorship and disinformation i
think i think it is eventually going to
break and it's going to be something
they can't contain that is a billion
times bigger than hunter biden and even
bigger than the vaccine disinformation
and everything else and i think it's
this we already know that the national
institutes for health gave money to echo
health alliance to do gain of function
research at the wuhan lab in china where
they in and not just that that in doing
so we know that they created at least
one virus that became 10 000 times more
deadly than it was when they started
with the the gain of function research
and they were using humanized mice they
actually uh put i think they graphed
human ears on the mice or something like
that they were through uh something with
uh the jeans strange look yeah yeah it's
a strange look but they do something
with the human it's they call them
humanized mice and it's it's how they do
the gain of function research that now
has it where it now can spread to humans
and it was 96 percent similar to covid
to sars co cov 2 the the virus that
causes covet 19. now we know that and
what the government's response was is
after first blocking it from you know
for quite some time and saying this is
misinformation this is a russian hoax
whatever they were saying then when it
finally came out that it was true they
went well but there's no proof that that
virus that's 96 similar uh ended up
becoming covet okay fair enough i don't
really know how that works how big of a
gap that four percent is they were
making viruses that were strikingly
similar to the one that has killed over
a million people in the u.s and millions
more around the country in the wuhan lab
which is where this spread now go even
further with that when sars came out the
first sars because this is actually the
second sars when the first stars came
out in o3 the chinese government leapt
to action the governments around the
world left the action and they tried to
contain it as much as they could and out
of that they said okay and we're going
to put in we're going to have you know a
a red line or a hotline set up we're
going to make it so that if if something
like this spreads again we're going to
move even faster
and then when this one came out they
arrested people for saying it was real
they arrested people they arrested the
chinese doctor i forget his name he
ended up dying of covet for saying that
this was a new version of sars that's
not the action of a government that
wants to be sure to contain uh this new
virus and let everyone know about it i
believe i don't know this but i believe
that eventually the truth will come out
that either the u.s or another
government possibly the chinese
government possibly the british or some
other government
through ecohealth alliance or a company
like it did gain a function research in
a lab in wuhan that should not that was
not equipped to handle that level of of
of
essentially a bio weapon or a virus a
virus that they were creating and then
it leaked because because it turns out
government is inept so you so you agree
with the position trump took to to
stop travel and all of that from uh
during that time once here it didn't
matter anymore once covet is here the
way that it spreads it didn't matter
anymore and that was something i i said
uh you know i think the one time that it
might have made sense to do a temporary
stop was with ebola because ebola
doesn't spread as easily so it's
literally a person giving it to another
person who might give it to another
person and so that i could i could hear
the argument for that even though you
can easily screen for ebola long before
they get here so but regardless with
kovid especially now with these newer
variants but even with the original
variant the alpha variant whatever it
was that came it originally
it's already spread more easily than the
flu
so once one person has it here any kind
of mitigation of trying to stop people
who might have coveted from
that you weren't going to be able to do
anything and it was it was here before
we realized that it was here
did you guys see the daily wire story
about fauci and collins did you did you
see the the royalties the sheridan
secret nih royalties totaling 350
million dollars i just see that
between the two of them in the 10-year
period they got 350 million dollars paid
out and the report from openthebooks.com
said the royalty payments included at
least 23
to fauci and 14 to his former boss
collins who were paid out between 2010
and 2020. yeah i mean these stories the
more and more they come out this guy is
unbelievably corrupt and look fauchy was
basically the head
corporatist chill i mean he was the guy
at the national health institute who's
making the decisions who gets grant
money you know like he's the king maker
with taxpayer funds of who's going to
get funded and so of course those guys
who are doling out favors like that are
almost always in these situations taking
some type of other favor and return it i
can just tell you watching the guy it's
just so obvious the way he's like well
the answer to everything is you have to
consume this pharmaceutical product from
these pharmaceutical companies i don't
care what your situation is what you had
it a month ago and you have natural
immunity no still need to go get boosted
still need to go get another one he's
supporting i mean this whole thing was
so obviously a scheme where you're like
wait so the government is going to
mandate that you have to
consume a product made by one of these
three companies which are granted the
intellectual property rights to make
them and then you have to keep buying
another and ingesting another one of
these products every six months or
whatever it is and then the head doctor
scientist guy is telling you that we
support this policy happening by the way
it's all funded by taxpayer dollars so
it's free you know every one of these
jabs is free and luckily i do think this
is at least falling apart a little bit
where now you're seeing the data suggest
that like getting this fourth booster
gives you like six weeks of protection
maybe and then like what i mean this is
insane that anyone would by the way a
year ago what you were saying was beyond
controversial oh this would have been
you would be beyond removed from you
yeah okay you guys genuinely be like
maybe you can't put this episode up but
i was saying this a year ago by the way
i was saying this a year ago yeah my
point is you would have been black bald
band shadow band now you're like yeah
this guy dave's actually
what i wondered earlier what what what
kovid did for many people was allowed to
explode if you were already big but if
you weren't already big you were crushed
because i've been shadow banned like
there's no tomorrow i mean just my my
shadow banning is horrible throughout
everything because i was against the
mandates and the second i said i was
against the mandates all of a sudden my
show goes down to
every all my everything's i stopped
growing i thought that was losing people
i mean oh and i'm blue checked i'm i'm
literally a candidate and they just
shadow banned me like there's no
tomorrow it's terrible so what'd you do
you went to parlor you went to i'm on
all the things now i'm tick-tocking
and yes i do everything now because
there's no way i can get out rumbling
everything half of his money the half a
million dollars came from his only fans
account
right now
raising money i mean what a strategic
incredible very impressive i saw that
story don't you hate honolulu incredible
a year ago i was threatened with having
posts removed and content removed for
disinformation for saying that based on
two things based on the fact that uh the
data from that they were shared what
data they would share with us from the
vaccines showed that its efficacy would
last anywhere from three to nine months
give or take
and the fact that covet was not going
anywhere this was not if we weren't
going to get covet zero this was now an
endemic thing
those two things combined mean there are
going to have to be boosters for kovit
just saying vaccine booster kovid got me
threatened with disinformation
right now
and even before that saying that there
was going to be a vaccine mandate would
get you threatened with disinformation
absolutely
we've been through multiple vaccine
mandates across the country including
where you guys live and uh and also and
and where where jessica lives as well uh
and then also we i mean boosters are now
get your booster you got you're not
really vaccinated if you don't get your
booster
maybe and i know this might be a tough
sell in this crowd but maybe
allowing there to be as many different
people
adding to the conversation good and bad
might lead
to falsehoods being ferreted out through
better information no maybe no hold on
larry
i know before the show that you and dave
endorsed aoc it's true but
private but in private caught but yes
hear me out
maybe
if we have as many people contributing
to the conversation as possible and as
many people being involved in it as
possible and as many different sources
of information as possible we might have
a better chance of sorting out what's
true and what isn't and maybe the people
who i know but maybe the people who are
in charge who have a vested interest in
protecting specific narratives on every
single subject
don't want that to happen um
and it's really it's hard to even like
look back to like 2020 and and because
everything moves so fast that you almost
forget what happened the enormous
propaganda campaign yeah behind cuomo
and fouch and that everything they were
doing was just so noble and beyond
question that you just couldn't even
have another opinion without being this
like evil person who just wanted grandma
to die and all of this stuff but it's
amazing so new and so disruptive yeah
you didn't really know the answer
well it's a lot easier to do that now
two years later and after we've seen but
what the yes that's true vaccine so it
was tough at the time no it was it was
very tough but in march 2020 i put on a
series of videos which was and i still
have it if you go to my youtube page you
can still find it it's a series it says
little coveted response march 2020. i
put out exactly how we should deal with
kovid in march 2020 so it wasn't any
harder that was two years ago that's
when it first came out and i put
policies down that were libertarian that
would actually make things better and we
look back now they weren't perfect i
didn't know everything back then but
without question everything i said to do
would have been better than what we did
in new york state it's part it's hard to
spot if you're not spotting the pattern
and the pattern is crisis happens either
created or made worse by government
government steps in and says don't
problem don't no problem don't worry
about it we have strong men and we have
strong policies and they're going to fix
all of this and all you have to do is
just obey us and if you don't obey us or
if you even question obeying us you're a
bad person okay and then when that
utterly fails or continues to make
things worse they go ah
what actually happened is that enough of
you you didn't believe hard enough you
didn't follow what we said hard enough
you're out there spreading
disinformation and saying things that
aren't true it's your fault which is why
we or it's their fault it's not your
fault because you're the good person
that's listening to us but it's their
fault the bad people who aren't you know
going along with the program that's
going to fix all of this if you just all
listen to it hey before we wrap up two
topics i'm curious to know what the
position is with libertarian
taxes so right now we got you know we
put the number between 80 to 120 whether
it's our national debt or unpaid or
under you know medicare so put them all
together 80 to 120 trillion dollars that
we got a libertarian person you become a
president 2024 you win what happens to
our taxes what do you do well i mean uh
i would work
to repealing every tax that i possibly
could i mean there's nothing the the i
mean if you're talking about the debt
that we have that's one thing and the
only answer to that is to is to um
essentially cut spending and default on
what we're going to default on because
there's no way we could ever tax
ourselves the 100 trillion dollars in
unfunded liabilities that we have coming
up over the next few decades but look my
buddy scott horton who's everyone here
knows a brilliant libertarian he always
puts it this way right but if you're
thinking about like the income tax
imagine we didn't have an income tax we
didn't have an irs and we were just
living in like a free country and uh the
vladimir putin invaded let's say the
soviet union invaded and conquered
america and they took over you know they
created the uss irs they said now we
have this organization and we have just
dictated in this country that um
producing things is a crime
being a productive member of
society is a crime and the punishment is
a fee and the more productive you are
the higher your fee is going to be and
we are suspending the fifth amendment
you no longer have the right to not
incriminate yourself you are legally
obligated to incriminate yourself every
single year you no longer have the right
to privacy you must give us all of your
information and we will look over we
will ruin your life if we want to we
will destroy families lead to suicides
go back 20 years if we want to and
demand all of your records if that was
created we would all very clearly go we
have been taken over by a totalitarian
regime and this is not the way that free
people live there it is it is despicable
in a professed free society that we have
an irs or an income tax i would abolish
it as soon as i possibly could um and
then abolish all other taxes as well
there's there's no need for any of this
whole system and it doesn't even matter
i mean look at the way we print money
and spend money it's completely
untethered from how much tax revenue we
raise what do you do with the debt you
are to china and japan well i think that
um there's basically the whether this
happens now or later there we're going
to end up defaulting on this debt in one
of several different ways now same like
we did with the gold standard basically
this is what richard nixon did when he
took us off the gold standard it was a
big giant default we had made a promise
that we would redeem our dollars in gold
france was like we want the gold and we
were like no you can't have it because
we don't have enough because we printed
way more money than we have gold to back
it up now whether we do this through
printing money and just basically saying
we'll pay back the debt but it'll be you
know with dollars that are worth much
less than they were when you borrowed
them that's a form of default that
default also destroys your own economy
in the process i think it would be much
better off uh if we were to just uh
acknowledge the reality of the situation
which is that this government is
bankrupt does not have this money um
never was in a position where it could
pay this money back the result of that
would probably be our uh national credit
rating uh being tanked and that people
wouldn't lend us money in the future so
we'd have to drastically shrink the size
of government
which all that's kind of what that's
kind of what i'm looking for anyway the
idea that we that we can pay this money
back without you know destroying the the
country the country is insane and to be
honest i don't think the taxpayer owes
it you know like i don't think the
taxpayer didn't like borrow this money
from people governments borrowed this
money on behalf of the taxpayer this
isn't like a true debt like in a private
sense where you borrowed money this is
like if you borrowed a whole bunch of
money for your children
saying they'll pay back the debt and
then you just bought yourself a bunch of
like jets and you know uh you know a
bunch of nice boats and stuff like that
and tanks right and then they go they go
okay well does your kid owe that money
back i'd say no they didn't borrow the
money i don't think you have a right to
say the next generation owes this money
well and this isn't even i mean it's
it's the next generation too but even
the current generation yeah if i walked
in here with a gun and said uh great
news uh you owe all this money that i
just ran up but the good news is i have
a new house new car knew everything
yachts i started a war uh but here are
you also you now owe all this money you
don't actually owe that money i i i
cringe every time i see a politician go
we're america we pay back our debts good
you pay it back
we didn't consent to this we did not
agree to this we did not sign this this
is not an actual debt that is owed now
another question is okay but without
taxes how does government fund itself
and the short answer to that is they're
gonna have to fund themselves way
everyone else funds themselves
voluntarily if you aren't a government
or a criminal organization and in fact a
lot of criminal organizations fund
themselves through voluntary commerce
but the ones that don't that are that
are thugs like how government operates
they fund themselves through extortion
and protection rackets and that's what
government does and surprise surprise
that we don't get the best value out of
a protection racket when someone comes
in and says great place you got here be
ashamed if anything was to happen to it
and then they rob you the end of that
story is that they do a great job
protecting you it's just that they don't
break up your store and they keep
charging you more and more and more so
that they don't break up your store we
need to force government to figure out
how to fight get people to want to give
money to it and there are ways to do
that you can have direct fees for
services you can have like a voluntary
transaction fee which would basically be
like a small insurance policy on any
transaction you do if you want to pay it
fine if you don't find if you don't pay
it you're not protected you can't use
the courts to sue if something goes bad
with that transaction or whatever and in
doing it that way government would have
to make whatever that fee is worth it
no one's going to want to pay 40 or 50
percent transfer tax but five percent
maybe so now that forces government to
actually live within its means because
right now it actually government does
live within its means it means is
whatever amount of money it tells the
federal reserve to run up and lend to it
we needed to live with them within the
means of what we wanted to do and the
only way that's ever going to happen is
taking away its ability to extort all of
us under threat of harm there's a big
problem here though most americans are
happy with taxes
in fact every time they do polling no
matter what it is every time a year
whoever runs the polls you can check one
now online if you want to what do
americans think about taxes there's
always a chunk of americans who
literally say we're not taxed enough
so americans overall are okay with taxes
so we have to change the american psyche
on tax absolutely i think the first step
is believe it or not simplifying all the
tax code is the number one thing as
president i would push is to simplify
all that i'd have to fight all the
accountants fight all the finance
industry fight all the tax prep people
but simplify the tax code do you want a
flat tax what would you want flat tax is
fine everyone pays x percent you you as
long as it's zero i'm cool well
that's a joe jorgensen no but the first
that's a ron paul line joe jorgensen's
was i'm cool with any new tax plan as
long as the rate is zero percent so what
but you want to you want to make sure
that the people will accept it and
people are going to be unhappy if
everyone pays the same rate it's just
how americans are so you've got to
somehow say whatever is the poverty rate
say for sake of argument 18 000
so any money up taking thousand dollars
is untaxable that makes people who are
worried about taxing the poor feel safe
after that one dollar have to say
eighteen thousand oh whatever number i
made the number up but say after that is
now taxed a flat fee ten percent five
percent i don't care what the percent is
no matter what that's the percent
however you get your money in that's the
percent number one second i don't want
to take money out of out of paychecks i
want people to write a check for their
taxes in april that's how we collect
taxes i want you to write that check to
pay your taxes every year so you're
feeling it i already know i already do
it yes the average person that comes out
of your paycheck that's correct i want
you to go i'm writing a check am i
getting what i want out of this what's
10.99 of business owners do yes yeah you
know the crazy thing you should do you
know the crazy thing that will change we
can do what they're talking about do you
know who came up with tax withholding
and when he was on his math that he was
the
biggest regret oh man of my life milton
friedman is that right yeah i know that
i know this is the reason for it he
literally dated the withholding time and
he said it's the biggest mistake i made
fyi
in
1862
lincoln said we need money folks he went
and taxed america wasn't a big number
seven percent i think was tears of three
percent six percent some small number
like that civil war he said once we pay
off the civil war we'll stop taxes do
you think taxes stop
it did nine years later there was no
taxes because we paid it off nice and
then the next time around 1903 all this
other time that's when everything else
showed up right okay so that's tax
concept let's go to row uh v wait right
oh that's not controversial yeah let's
end on something wait a minute pelosi
pelosi just had a bunch of pro-abortion
people in front of uh
her house if you can pull that up
pro-abortion activists are protesting
outside of nancy pelosi i was accusing
her of being complicit and destroying
abortion rights this is a blaze story
uh where we are with this story at the
top a small group of small group of
protesters demonstrated outside of
politics is a palatial mansion in san
francisco california we're here because
nancy pelosi and the whole leadership of
the democratic party has been complicit
complicit with the fascist republican
party that wants to not only eliminate
abortion rights but gay marriage trans
rights and a whole slew of rights said
the protester the protests appear to be
organized by the far left pro-abortion
called ruth sent us that demeaned uh
demanded pelosi investigate a supreme
court justice in order to save abortion
so what's what's the libertarian
position on roe v
wade i think by the way it just it
reminds me these these crazy protesters
turning on nancy pelosi it's like a
monster she created that turns out did
you ever hear um when john kerry he's on
that that that secret recording where
he's talking about the rise of isis in
syria and he's he's like basically
saying he's like look we knew all the
weapons and money we were sending in was
going to isis but we were going to use
them to put pressure on assad so he'd
have to step down and then they just
went into iraq and it's like no one told
you to do that you're like yeah i guess
you can't control isis as well as you
thought shocker you would like yeah
that's a dangerous game to play um but
look i think the the immigration and
abortion are probably two of the issues
where there are a lot of libertarians on
different sides um personally i'm
pro-life um so i i've i'm on that side
of that uh that position so i'm happy
with roe v wade being overturned but i
do also think that libertarians could
could probably at least
understand even the pro-choice ones that
when you have an issue like abortion
where there is no national consensus you
have tens of millions of people who are
on different sides of this issue and
very passionately on different sides of
this issue and then you have one federal
edict out of the supreme court that says
this is the law of the land it doesn't
matter what you think in your area well
the result of that has been 50 years
50 years this has been a white hot
cultural wedge issue that's never gone
away and the result of roe v wade being
overturned would be that what the states
can make up their own rules and it's a
very you know like it's a it's a very
difficult issue to solve when one side
sees it as the most fundamental right
women have and the other side sees it as
murdering babies like that's a very
difficult bridge to divide and i don't
see any reason why the policy in rural
alabama has to be the same as the policy
in portland or brooklyn or something
like that i think communities should be
able to decide for themselves
larry so you guys want to skip this one
you seem very quiet you've been very
vulnerable until this one came up i
wouldn't let him say his name
um no i i think the reality of it is um
if you're going to solve this issue you
have to begin to draw lines
and people don't want to draw lines
because you're saying do you have some
one part that says it doesn't matter you
know no matter what it's my my body my
choice up until
your day before the baby's born and the
other side that says no it is it is
murder upon conception
somehow we have there is that consensus
the vast majority of americans think
that roe v wade should not be overturned
that's that's demonstrable most
americans believe should not be
overturned most americans think there
should be
some some limitations on abortion but
abortion should be legal that's what
most americans think now in the
libertarian party it is very split
you're totally right i know a lot of
libertarians who are pro-life and their
point is you're attacking a life
therefore that's that's aggressive you
can't do that we have to draw a line
somewhere that's really the issue is
that line in my personal view that line
cannot be into the third trimester it's
got to be before that but i don't know
where that line is to be forward you
have to draw a line and we draw that
line it's going to suck for some people
but i think you have to draw especially
the babies correct yes i think you have
to draw do you draw a line
a couple of weeks a couple of months
you've got to draw a line somewhere i
think you simply draw a line and when
you and when the consensus i think will
probably be by state on how they would
draw their eyes some will just say no
matt you can't have it except say rape
or incest or something that'll be their
line i think each state's going to draw
the wrong line i think you have to it's
the only way you solve it is by drawing
lines life begins at conception the
question is when does personhood begin
and there that's the problem even within
the libertarian movement really the
argument within the libertarian movement
is just a reflection of the argument in
society in america and in every single
honestly in many countries
is when does that personhood begin when
is this no longer an extension just a
something an extension of the mother and
when is this now an actual its own human
beings that that should be uh that
should be have its rights protected i
personally consider myself pro-life i
think that abortion is uh more often
than not gruesome and regrettable i
think that the talk of it just being
this choice i mean we're we're talking
about something that otherwise would
have become a human being whether we're
talking about at the moment of
conception or you know
as it's crowning you know but before the
actual birth has been completed this is
something that ultimately would have
become a human and i think that that
gets lost on the pro-choice side what
gets lost on the pro-life side is
the war on drugs has created more drug
use and empowered cartels to sell drugs
and has the government sponsoring drug
cartels the war on illegal immigration
has led to the humanitarian crisis on
the border and cartels being empowered
and millions of people here illegally
both for good and bad reasons the war on
terror has led to the government
sponsoring terror groups and and you
know terrorists taking over entire
countries like in what just happened in
afghanistan the war on poverty has led
to a growing gap between those who have
and those who don't a permanentization
of generational poverty what do we think
the war on abortion is going to look
like yes and that's not that's not an
open that's not a a a
you know an open question we can pretty
easily guess first of all they're gonna
have to draw what that line is
it's likely just for convenience that
the line is gonna because it's hard to
verify anything else except conception
so it's gonna get drawn likely at or
near conception but so now
i saw this picture the other day that i
think spike you may like so i saw this
where scientists on the left are saying
look
there's atoms there's life on mars this
is awesome
right there's actual bacteria we found
life on mars and then on the right no no
no that's not life it's it's not a it's
not a life a person exists at birth no
he's not inside the mother which is
which is that's why i'm validating him
showing that for him but also no i mean
it's just i i i i was a i used to be a
pro-choice guy and it was i i started
kind of changing my mind on it and then
it was after having kids that i really
just completely changed and was like
very pro-life and it's just it's even
the argument of personhood it's like
well okay i mean if someone's in a coma
and they're gonna come out of the coma
in five days you could argue like they
don't really have personhood in this
moment but you know what the future is
no i'm not saying one question
no no no i'm saying they had personhood
well what would make a fetus even after
conception not have personhood but but
here's the problem they have a unique
dna so they have like so they're going
to become a baby they might be at a
different stage of development is
obviously you're right but the point is
to what you just i wasn't disagreeing no
i actually agree with you on that yeah
what i'm focusing on guys i just thought
a curtain
i guess you know who's i just had a
crazy idea but i'm anti-abortion so let
me be clear enough i want to you know
three men arguing each other about
abortion we have a lady here we'd
probably want to get her opinion but
um
in general and this leads to my question
to jessica and teeing her up
should men not even have a say in this
should this be an
all-woman-decided issue no it's
twenty-two
babies should women be the ones deciding
this not
a room full of uh men in a in a
back
uh office old white men deciding what
women need to do with their bodies
listen with those glasses you put on
what a gentleman you are i'm trying to
be a gentleman here i was so jessica
miss vaughn what do you think um well i
think abortion should have always been a
state's right issue i don't understand
why uh there needs to be some
national oversight on the ethics for
local communities on that
so um but but also
what was the question you just asked
asks
oh if men are allowed okay well
obviously you can't procreate without
men so why should they not have equal
i'm just putting that out there all
right well
it's a weird thing as women
yeah but when you're a father like okay
yes that is true like women it is
biologically true that women go through
a lot more to have babies but the idea
that the man has no stake
if like your kids it's just that's just
a control that's a controlled way
to shut you down i'm just gonna say the
chappelle joke okay well if that's the
case then i guess we should be okay with
dead beat dads they're making a choice
not to be yeah i thought chappelle's
joke was the best to argue that last but
not least trump well i want to i want to
answer this one piece if i could you can
you could i am pro-choice but
anti-abortion what does that mean to
your point if if i'm pro-life i'm saying
i want the government to make it illegal
if i'm saying that the outcome will be
poor women will be punished and i'm not
about punishing poor women that's the
outcome ireland even slapped about an
abortion because the wealthy women flew
to london and get abortions and the poor
irish woman got screwed
i do not want to punish poor women this
is why i'm pro-choice however i am
anti-abortion which means i will do
things to ensure and i promise as
governor there will be less abortions in
new york i will do things to make things
better for example i will make sure that
people can get um contraception without
a prescription over the counter no
matter what it is i will make sure their
adoption and surrogacy will be simple
and easy and cheap so that people who
want who want to have a baby but don't
want to have an abortion there'll be
families there to pick them up and take
them easily that day no more adoptions
in china romania all in new york state
there will be less abortions in your
state and the most important thing which
some people think is crazy but i think
it's very important we should be taking
all the money energy and time we spend
towards fighting roe v wade and put it
towards artificial wombs once you have
an artificial womb that is functioning
cheap abortion becomes obsolete
marriage then also becomes obsolete i'm
sorry why would we have to have families
at all if you have artificial wombs
that's like brave new world territory we
already don't have family family's
already broken up that's not because
artificial wounds is because well that's
just another step towards that
maybe but i'm okay with it that one i'll
take we it just went from safe legal and
rare and went all the way to the leading
cause of death on the planet yeah so
like that's the leading cause of death
is abortion yeah i i i it and they you
know the black genocide there's a
there's a lot of things that can be said
about that on how that came about years
ago on what the whole reasoning behind
it is where if you really go and study
the history of it it's not a good
history by the way you know it's almost
like they want to keep that history
quiet in history no they do everything
they can to not talk about margaret
saying or speaking to the kkk
you make a very good point and to to
uh help minimize towards marriage uh i
think there's been two people who have
been heavily campaigning to
uh uh influence single men to stay
single i think one of the biggest
campaigners her name is jada pinkett and
the other one is amber hurt so they have
not
yes make sure you don't uh marry someone
like that um but there's you know my
message to guys is always like i think
marrying the right woman which i'm
fortunate enough to have done is the
best thing you could ever do in your
life and but the thing is this right
crazy women like that
you and this is crazy men too for women
out there you will get red flags the
question is whether you're ignoring them
or not there is not there were a million
red flags for all of the people in these
relationships they chose to ignore them
so it's just as simple as when you're
dating someone if they show you a red
flag you know maybe ignore one buy the
second one end it and uh you'll you'll
be fine let's find yourself a good woman
i don't stay single libertarian dating
advice but i
i have to
you gotta have them on the podcast just
to talk about dating oh yeah you're
ready i'll do it i've been i've been
married 20 years from a girl i met
actually in high school
and as part of my consulting i actually
have helped women in new york city get
married so i'm happy to have that
comment that's a medal of honor now
correct
larry can i book you absolutely
i've been married
i've been married for 12 years and no
one including myself understands why my
wife
like that's it is you out kicked your
coverage always it's not even it's it's
what they did
what's your anniversary march 27th okay
got it yeah i married up too i'm with
you i'm married yeah so so last but not
least folks if you're enjoying today's
format and the way we did it
and if you're joining the guests that we
had on here today with the banter going
back and forth
give it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel and make sure you go send this
video on twitter and put the handle musk
say meet with these folks and see if the
libertarian concept makes sense last
thing
trump just endorsed 11 folks nine of
them won okay and you know what that
means when it's 9 out of 11. that's
great that's steph curry type of
free-throw shooting that you're doing
elections around the corner no matter
how much [ __ ] people talk and say the
guy's over with
he's running 99 chance and he's gonna be
the nominee for the right
and there's a high likelihood he wins
because desantis is not running not this
time around the santa's probably gonna
wait till running for 2027 2028 and
running this time i may be wrong it's my
speculation okay
um
what where do you stand with what's
going to happen in 2024 with trump
winning how how much different do you
think the climate is going to be one do
you think he'll win two if he wins how
different of an america is 2024 versus
when he won in 2016.
well i think that um i be i more or less
agree with your assessment i think that
if donald trump wants it i don't think
desantis is going to challenge him in a
primary you don't think he could be a
running mate uh that's that's possible
would he be a vp pick i mean that that i
could
too
yeah probably not the best for uh for
trump
i don't know about that but i don't
think he'll run for the nomination look
i think you have a base in the
republican party a huge percentage of
the base genuinely believes that donald
trump is the legitimate president yeah
and that joe biden wasn't legitimately
elected that's a huge percentage of the
base in the republican party the he has
beloved amongst the republican base
still i think if that that nomination is
his if he wants it and then
i don't i really don't know if joe biden
ends up running for re-election but it's
either him or kamala harris either way
the weakest candidate that the democrats
could possibly feel to be honest i don't
see how
you have a democrat president after 2024
i mean what do they have to run on they
have inflation media dominance lockdown
i mean it just people it's like look
we're the party who wants to like kick
you out of your job if you don't get a
vaccine that doesn't even work um we
want to destroy your dollar and we want
to prop a guy propaganda is your
six-year-old with like sex education or
something like that these are not
popular positions and the truth is that
donald trump running man is going to
bring just a hell storm of media
insanity and it'll be i think hilarious
and weird but i the country is at a very
different place donald trump is older i
mean i know go we got used to joe biden
being so old
and he's really like 15 years older than
his actual age um but donald trump in
what i've seen in the clips of his
rallies i think he's just like
he doesn't quite have the magic to me
that he had in 2016. i think he's a
little out of touch with where his base
is a little out of touch with where the
country is i've seen him like bragging
about how he made the vaccines and the
people in his crowd are kind of like
we're like not really
that's not really our thing
you know we're kind of anti yeah
i don't know
so i still think he could win but i do
think this is a it's a different
landscape and a different dynamic than
than 2016 so i'm interested to see how
it all plays out 81 million people
didn't vote for joe biden they voted
against donald trump
when you combine that with the fact that
as dave was saying i i mean trump has
been booed a couple of times at his
rallies like i do think he's kind of
like kind of lost track of some of some
of his base and it's his base that he
relies on i think that if donald trump
if donald trump runs from the nomination
it is
basically a certainty that he will get
the republican nomination
i think that the only way
that the that joe biden kamala harris
whoever it is that is the democrat
candidate can try to change the subject
from the at that point the last four
years of them being in office and the
consequences of that as well as bad
policies that happen under trump that
they supported like stimulus spending
and things like that the only way they
can change the subject is to make it a
litmus test on someone that a good
percentage of the country hates
like donald trump so i don't know if
donald trump is the best for the
republican party to run now even big as
a libertarian
you'll notice that none of us here tried
to seriously say that a libertarian has
a shot in 2024 that is a problem
that's why i started no that's fair
that's fair that's why i started you are
the power is because we have to grow
from the grassroots up to be able to
make it so that one day there is serious
contention for a libertarian libertarian
candidate in 2024 not with a series of
lightning strike hail mary passes that
all seem to work out but with an actual
feasible plan to be able to do that
there are two pieces i want to bring up
one is libertarian piece libertarian
party's goal in 2024 should be to get
electoral votes that's what it should be
there should be gold on that map whether
that is whether that's utah or chunk of
nebraska whether that's a chunk of maine
who splits up their stuff whether that's
new mexico whatever it is wyoming there
should be a gold piece on that map
because that map is shown a bazillion
times and that map is what will get us
to be real so we have a real shot at
winning in 2028 so we must get some type
of electoral victory in 2024 as far as
trump goes i'm not sure trump is going
to run there is value in him being king
maker and i think he does like it he
might decide to be king maker um if he
runs i think he will absolutely win the
nomination without question i think
that's guaranteed but he might go you
know what i like being the puppet master
i'm gonna sit back and endorse you and
nurse you you guys go he might say i
still think that's an option for him to
do but i think if he does run he'll make
it if the if the republicans run a
desantis gabbard ticket or something
like that someone desantis cannot get
the left but someone like a gabbard or
someone like that whatever the person
says who can get the left off this is
the second name you're saying gabard
like yeah
okay got it
can draw the left right it's anyone who
to the left if the republicans get a
desantis and someone who can draw the
left they will easily sweep it um the i
think trump will can still win but the
issue is will there be a culture war
issue that will pop up that year like
abortion is now if a culture war issue
pops up republicans might lose in 2024
if not they're going to win the issues
only will they and the reason why i say
it is i know people in new york state
lots of them they are not democrats some
of them i know are not democrats they're
republicans this bro we bait we v wade
thing popped up they are angry
they are mad they are pissed off and it
doesn't affect them at all in new york
state you are not affected whatsoever by
this and they are angry so who's angry
exactly women republican women and
independent women are angry at this even
though it does not affect them at all
they're still angry so if there is a
cultural issue that pops up then
republicans may struggle no culture or
republicans yeah the other major
manufactured culture well
the other the other major x factor is a
hot war
some type of real hot war that develops
that changes everything good point two
years away you never know what's going
on if that happens we have to stay out
let them let them hashtag i would i
certainly would like to
and i think he was more referring to
either starting or conflagrating a war
because presidents in wartime tend to
get re-elected and that that might be a
this is an exception though this isn't
like it's a very weird president an
interesting time yes very weird yeah
it's also true you know it's and it's
people on both sides are just kind of
like what the
let's just
everyone's like yeah when i was in
military i would in boot camp i don't
know if you remember we would count down
the days okay how many days do i have
left and you go there's there's people
people in their closets no one sees
they're counting down how many days are
left with the current administration to
get somebody else to take over
left and right by the way it's not just
like it's only people on the right in
the middle anyways right folks this has
been great thank you so much for coming
out all of you uh i i uh i'm sure the
audience uh loved the content i was
looking at the commentary going back and
forth uh and hopefully now folks you can
make up your mind for yourself if this
is something you're more interested in
let's put the links of everybody below
put the larry sharps and see his
campaigning right now if they want to go
find out more about it yeah
to go to go find out more about him and
then stay close to everybody here we'll
put all the links below for people to
follow you more importantly by the way
you look like a hollywood star dude what
exactly is
make sure
subscribe to the channel if you want to
see more of this a lot of our viewers
are just us this is more pictures of
larry sharpes
no no i think that's that the picture
does it though it's the picture it's all
about the picture what do we have next
tuesday do we have uh mark morano the
author of green fraud we'll go into
climate change we're going climate
change too this is great nuclear
libertarian green frog fantastic love
that folks have a great weekend take
care bye-bye
you